안녕하십니까. 시밀턴 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝
브리프입니다. 오늘은 7월 13일
월요일입니다. 지난 주말 내내
더웠는데요. 잘 지내셨는지
모르겠습니다. 지난주 금요일 중국
시장 방정님과 함께 보겠습니다.
>> 네. 지난 주 금요일는 차시 매물
추형으로 상 지수 맨너스 1% 정도는
빠져왔어요. 흥성태그 지수는 맨너스
염증 2% 소포하라하고 정시 과대는
삼점 자조향까지 올라왔습니다. 업종별
좀 보시면 부동산 표준 소비제
헬스케어 업종인 건세웠고 반면은 IT
커뮤니케이션 에너지 업정이
약세되었습니다.
저가 매수 자금이 위부로 소비체
관련주 오라 하고요. 귀주모했는 2%
올라고 우리 아이는 4%번주는 5%
히트리는 + 2% 돌아왔어요.이 개별
주시 특별한 이슈가 없습니다. 뭐
2분기 허실적 그리고 저가 매수 자극
유입으로 헬스케어 권련주도
반등하고요. 제한은 플러스 염증 3%
만서 이어는 1.5% 50는 + 2%
올라왔어요. 기계 해외 수출 데이터
허조에 따라서 기계 관련주도
올라왔습니다. 세밀 중공업는 + 2%
종량 종관은 + 2.3% 나왔어요.
어 이번게 허실적 그리고 원자재 선물
가격가 반등도 허제인버 소재 관련주
올라왔습니다. 충분는 알루미늄 +
3% 강석은 5% 승산 아루미늄 5%
올라왔어요. 6월 달 전기차 수출
데이터 시전 예상치 대비 상후등요
전기차 거주 반등 나왔습니다. VD는
3.6% 상해 자동차는 플러스
2%으로 나왔어요. 한편은
흥성테크주는 강세 지수되고 있습니다.
아리바바는 + 2% 니오토는 1.4%
쇼미는 3.4%라고요.
특히나 아래바 주관 보면은 17%
라왔고요. 쇼미는 12% 라왔습니다.
센트는 거의 7% 가까이
선성했습니다.
>> 반면은 찰시한 말추형으로 A 관영주
동반 하라했습니다. 어 신년물 고체
금리는 염정 1bp 하했습니다.
인연물 고체 금리는 1.5bp BP
상승하고 외양화 환율 염정 25%
정도 잘되었습니다.
>> 감사합니다. 한국도 미국도 저희가
이제 시장 시황 자료를 좀 보다 보면
연초에 좀 그랬다가 아니었다가 최근에
다시 그 마켓 브로드닝이라는 말들이
많이 나와요. 그래서 어 이제 지수가
오를 때 상승 종목 수가 얼마나 많이
어 있느냐 뭐 이렇게 말씀드려 볼
수도 있을 것 같은데 최근에 보면
한국도 미국도이 지수 상승에 동반하는
그 종목 수가 좀 많아지고 있거든요.
중국은 좀 어떤 거 같아요? 지난주
기준을 하면 시전은 빠졌잖아요.
80% 정도 그 개별 주시를 타고
올라왔습니다. 그러면 20% 주시
빠졌어요. 그런데 20% 주시는
대형주입니다.
>> 대형주는 분면은 주로 그 테크 주들이
빠졌어요. 그래서 지수는 1%에
빠졌는데 미테가 올라가지 못하는
주시잖아요.
>> 중서현주 다 받는 나왔어요.
>> 음.
중국도 물론 이제 상승할 때 하락할
때 어 많은 종목들이 보다 동반된다.
그러니까 대형주가 당연히 조금
역방향으로 움직이고 중소용주로 매기가
좀 몰린다. 이런 시장의 전반적인
시황은 한국이나 중국과 좀 유사하게
흐르는 거 같습니다.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 그냥 급 갑자기 궁금했는데 오늘
아침에 오다 보니까 미일한 전쟁
때문인지 미국 선물이 좀 안 좋아요.
네.
>> 어 미일한 전쟁 관련하는 거에
대해서는 중국은 뭐 보도나 보도의
어떤
비중이나 아니면
>> 어 뉴스에서 나오는 중국 정부
의견이나 그런 거 좀 있습니까?
>> 아 그거는 없어요. 다만 일본에 대한
의견 되게 많고요.
>> 어떤 거에 대한 일본에네
>> 그냥 여전히 둔네
맞아요. 네. 좋아.
>> 네. 그런 얘기는 조금 왕부분 창님이
준비해 주시면 다음에 좀 더 자세히
해 보겠습니다. 네.
>> 어. 오늘 준비해 주신 종목은
반복해서 저희 업데이트 해 주시는 거
같은데요. 대족테크입니다.
>> 맞아요. 대조는 실적 발표였어요.
실적 발표 후에는 지난주 금요일은
시전을 -1%에 빠졌지만이 회사는
플러스 2% 올라왔어요.이
글로벌 PCB 전비 1등 회사고요.
그리고 AI PCB 전비 수주 비전
55% PCB 트레이딩 전비 매출
비중 75% 정도 됩니다. 글로벌
MS 30% 그냥 1등주로 보시면
되고요. 한반계 수행위는 동의부터
280% 급증 예상이고 역산호 화면은
2번 기수 있는 동의
195%부터 364%를 급정했어요.
QQ도 거의 79% 이상 증가
예선입니다. 시장 예선시 대비
상호하는 실전 나왔어요. PCB 업체
대규모 증 업그레이드 등 요으로 거
같이 전비 매출 거장이 지소되고
있습니다. 원래 들어서 PGB 업체
케파 증문을 약 590억 위한 정도가
투표했어요. 정년 한해는 850억부터
900억 정도 됩니다. 그래서
역산으로 어 영환산으로 하면은 야산
10% 이상 증가 예상입니다.
>> ACB 전비 매출 비조 화대에다서
2번기 수위성 상향 조정 가능성도
있고요. 작년 4번기 GP 마진율
35.1%로 동의하고
원래 1번기 GP 마진율은
33.1%로 1%로 동의대비
3.5%보다 화대했어요. A용 PGB
트레이닝 장비 단가가 지금 그냥 팔원
정도입니다. 그래서 1번 트레이닝
정비보다는 어 거의 세배 이상은 또
높은 수준이 있고요. 그래서이 부분
매출 비중 화대하며 정차 GP 마년로
우라할 수 있습니다. 특히는
[콧방귀] 올해부터 1. 컨트레시브
로빙 시리즈 그 PB 출화 등가로
마진 추가 개선 가능성이 있고요.이
부분은 GP 마진 거의 45% 이상
나올 수 있어요.
>> 음.
관대 증거한 리포트 보면은 이번 시조
호조 A용 PCB 케파 투자 화때
커프가 같이 전비 매출 전가 등 요로
매수 의견을 제시했습니다. 롤래프다
내년 내년 순위 있는 각 20억
34억 47억 추정되었고 지전 대비는
각하 12% 18% 추가
상정했습니다.
어 무표 주가를 제시하지 않았어요.
그러면 2년 EPS CGR 계산
분위가 53% 나오고 있습니다.
그래서 PG는 대초는 1.3페
3패중이 있고요. 만약에 여기서는
1.5배를 타게 하면이 업세도 10%
이상 나올 수 있고요. 뭐 1.5배는
그 저당하는 수준이고요. 뭐 항선
맥스하면은 2배 정도 그 물라 할 수
있어요. 그래서 업세 나올 수
있습니다.
>> 최근에 [목을 가다듬음] 주시는 그
변호선 좀 많이 커졌어요. 그래서
혹시나 조전 받으면은 이런 회산 차도
괜찮다고 생각합니다.
>> 음. 우리 대족테크 오늘 실적 발표
아 실적이 아니죠. 업데이트해 주신
것 기준으로 한국 시장에 좀 함의를
>> 가질 수 있는게 있다면 뭘까요?
>> 아.
[콧방귀]
>> 음.
모르겠습니다. 이거 뭐냐면이 PCB
업체는 대충는 총구시장 글로벌 비조는
70% 정도 이상 됐고요.
>> 음.이
>> 장비 회는도 거의 충분히 1등로
잡았어요. 자리. 음주가 있는 거는
그렇게 뭐티 나는 건 없다고 생각하고
있고 아무튼이 어퍼는 할 수
있어요.이이
>> H PCB 쪽으로는 케바 정찰은 계속
하고 있으니까 수요 나쁘지 않다고
생각할 수 있고요. 그리고이 회자
정비 있잖아요.이 회자 정비는 미
2027년 말까지도 다 잡았어요.
수주까지. 음.
>> 그래서 2027년 전 뭐 지금
수준에도 2028년 나오셨어요. 음.
>> 그래서 현후 1년간 2년간 정설해도
무량이 없다고 생각할 수 있습니다.
>> 음. 음. 그렇게 이제 고정장할 수
있다고 믿으니까
>> 말씀해 주신 피지도 1배보다 훌쩍
넘었는데도 주가 조정은 없고 위에
밑에 PRPBR 차트를 봐도
>> 아 과거 밴드를 이렇게
>> 뚫은 상태인데 내려오지 않는 거
같습니다.
>> 어 오랜만에 이제 쭉 이렇게
뭐랄까요? 어 밸루에이션이 저 밑에
이렇게 좀 내려가 있는 종목들 많이
좀 훑어 주셨는데
>> 다시 시장 주도적으로 넘어오셨어요?네
네. 알겠습니다.
>> 대적 테크 시가총액이 32조원.
그러면 상대적으로는 [콧방귀]
조금
>> 큰 시가 총액이 큰 기업은 아닌 거
같아. 기업 치고는.
>> 아. 네. 거 대포 80조 이상 좀
뭐 큰 기업 보셔도 되고요.
>> 뭐 30조는 약간 종성형적으로 보시면
됩니다.
>> 자꾸 까먹어서 그런데 어네.
기업의이 티커 번호가 3으로 시작하면
한국에서
>> 아 맞아요.
>> 살 수 있다, 없다.
>> 살 수 없어요.
>> 개인들이 살 수 없습니다.
>> 알겠습니다.
자, 오늘 중국 시장 여기까지 보도록
하고 미국으로 넘어가 보겠습니다.
그럼 보니까 선물이 한 0.5% 5%
정도 하락하고 있던데 주말 [콧방귀]
사이의 뉴스들 또 어떤 것이
있었는지도 함께 좀 보도록
하겠습니다. 부탁드립니다. 지난주
미국 시장 말씀드리겠습니다. 지난
금요일 미국 정신은 어닝 시전 앞두고
소폭 상승한 채 마감해서 최고치
구원까지 올라섰고요. 나스닥에 대비한
SK 하이닉스 ADR이 공급가 대비
13% 오르며 성공적으로 신공식을
치렀습니다. 시장 전반을 살펴본 뒤
오늘은 UAE에 대한 AIP 수출
주제 완화랑 SK 하이닉스 ADR
상장 두 가지 정리해 드릴
예정입니다.음
음.
>> 왼쪽에 미국 주요 지수 먼저
보겠습니다. SP 500은 0.4%
오른 7,575로 마감하며 상승
이어갔고요. 음.
>> 나스닥과 [목을 가다듬음] 다우도
나란이 0.3% 상승하였고 러셀
2,000원 소폭 하락했습니다.
네.이란 긴장이 재점화되는 모습을
저번 주에도 보여줬는데 지소 반응을
좀 제한적으로 보였고요. 주가 주간
상승에도 금요일 하루 움직임은 크지
않았습니다. 네. SMP 500이 두
분기 연속 20% 이익 선장이
전망되는만큼
시장은 높아진 기대치가 실제 숫자로
확인되기를 기다리는 국면이 있는
것으로 보입니다.
다음으로 그 우측에 SP 500
업종별 보시겠습니다. 소재 1.1%
커뮤니케이션이 0.9%대 상승으로 좀
강한 모습 보여줬고요. 나머지 업종은
대체로 상승하는 모습 보여주었습니다.
반면 건강관리 업종이 0.8% 8%
하락으로 타워 업종 대비 약한 모습
보였습니다.
다음으로 금리와 유가 보시겠습니다.
미국체 10년물은 4.56%로
보합권이었습니다. WTI는 트럼프
대통령이 이란과의 휴전이 끝났다고
말하자 장중 반등했지만 협상은
이어가겠다고 밝히면서 데밀리구
0.8% 하락한 베러당 71.5달러로
5달러로 마감했습니다. 한 가지
짚어볼점은 주말사의 미분이 이번 주
세 번째 이번 주에 세 번째이죠 최대
규모인 140개 표적을
타격했고요.이란 [콧방귀]
혁명수비대가 호르무주의 봉쇄를 다시
선언했습니다. 다만 오늘 아침 개념한
유가 선물은이 소식에도 큰 변동 없이
거래되고 있는 모습 보이고 있고요.
[콧방귀] 그 미해군측은 남측 항론는
열려 있다고 밝히는 등 실제 물동량
차질이 제한적이라고 주장하고
있습니다. 네. 유가가 계속
안정된다면 이번 제역화가 주식 시장에
미출 영향은 크지 않을 것으로 저는
생각하고 있습니다. 다음으로 좌측
빅테크 및 주요 종목 보시겠습니다.
네. 전반적으로 어 큰 변동성은
나타나지 않았는데 반해서 메타가
6%대 급성하며 지수 상승분의 상당
부분을 차지한 것으로 보이고요. 지난
금요일 말씀드린 칩 모델 클라우드
전략에 대해 리서치 업체의 세미
애널리시스가 긍정적인 평가 보고서를
낸 것이 재료로 파악되고요. 보고서는
메타의 클라우드 진출이 코위브 같은
네오 클라우드를 장식하기보다 수요를
키운다는 분석이 주 내용이었습니다.
다음으로 주말에 나온 정책서 간략히
말씀드리겠습니다. 이 상무부가
UAE에 대한 수출 통제를 완화해서
M비디아 AI 집과 군사 장비 상업적
위성의 위성의 수출 절차를 대폭
간수하였습니다. 연방 관보에 따르면
UAE 정보와 승인된 기업들은 첨단
컴퓨팅 품목을 라이선스 없이 드려볼
수 있게 됐고 대상에는 UAE의
G42와 코어 42는 물론 현지에서
사업 중인 아마존 애플 구글 메타
마이크로소프트 오픈 AI 오라클
XAI와 그 자회사들이 포함됩니다.
MGX의 칩수출 라이선스 신청도
우호적으로 검토하겠다고 밝혔고요.
이러한 작전에서 UAE가 수행한
역할에 대한 보상 성격이 건부에
명시됐습니다.
2025년 5월 확정된 수십만 개
NBDI 집 수입 프레임워크의
연장선이기도 한 것으로 보입니다.
엔비디아와 하이퍼스케일러 입장에서는
이번 중동 데이터 센터 수요가 좀
정식으로 열리는 것이어서 AI 인프라
투자 사이클의 우호적인 재료로
판단됩니다. 다음으로 SK 하이닉스
ADR 성장 정리해 드리겠습니다.
경거부터 보시면 화요일 기간 총력
폭주하고 있다는 보도가 나왔고요.
마케팅 콜에 기간 190 올리며
목요일 공급가 149달러로
확정됐었습니다. 수요는 2,억 달러로
공급의 일곱배를 넘어왔고요. 금요일
첫 거래에서 ADR은 10 13%
상승하며 168달러로 마감했습니다.
조달 금융은 265억 달러로
2014년 알리바바를 넘어서 매국
기업 역대 최대 미국 성장이며 올해
미국 증시 전체로는 지난달 스페이스
X IPO 다음 규모입니다.
ADR 10주가 보통 주 한 주에
해당하고 이번 발행부는 총 발행
주식의 2.5%입니다.
또 달은 AI 반도체와 HBM 설비
투자에 쓰일 예정이며 7월 29일에에
아닙니다. 그리고 다음으로 그 상장
직후 최태현 회장의 발언도
나왔습니다. CNBC와 블룸버그
인터뷰에서 AI 시대 메모리 수요는
기아급수적으로 늘어난다고 했는데 형
5년간 생산 능력을 두 배로 늘려도
부족하고 일부 고객은 현재 다섯
배에서 여섯 배에 달하는 공급을
요구하고 있다고 밝혔습니다. AI
에이전트와 출론 학선으로 수요 구조
자체가 바뀌었고 공급 부족은 AI가
정착할 때까지 이어질 것으로
전망했습니다. 미국 투자와 관련해서는
인디아나 패키징 공장 외에 추가
투자를 검토 중이며 조건이 맞으면
메모리 공장 건설도 가능하다고
언급했습니다. AI론에 대해서는 일부
주가 과열은 있어도 기술은 현실이고
특금 비용 하락으로 누구나 AI를
쓰는 시대가 올 것이라고 답혔습니다.
그리고 마지막으로 이번 주 일정에
대해서 간략히 브리핑해 드리겠습니다.
화요일에 6월 10가 나오고요.
헤드라인 기준 전년 대비 3.8
8%로 5월 4.2%에서 둔화가
예상되고 있고 코는 2.8% 전망되고
있습니다. 그리고 같은 날씨
연준회장이 하원에서 수요일에는
상원에서 취임후 첫 의회 중원에
나서는데 연준 내부에서 동결과 인성을
둘러싼 논쟁이 진행 중인만큼
인플레이션 판단과 긴축 이지에 대한
발언 수위가 관건으로 보입니다.
실적은 화요일 JP 모건, 뱅커 오브
아메리카, 골드만스 등 대형 은행을
시작으로 수요일 ASML과 모건
스텔리로 목요일의 TSMC와 넷플릭스
유나이키드 헬스로 이어집니다. 특히
ASMR과 TSMC는 이번 반도체
랠리와 SK 하이닉스 상장 열리가
실제 수주와 실적으로 뒷받침되는지
확인할 수 있는 첫 시험대로
보입니다. 네. 다해서 오늘 내용
정리해 드리겠습니다. 음료율 시장은
어닝 시점을 앞둔 관망 속에 AK
SK 하이닉스가 외국 기업 역대 최대
상장 기록을 쓰고 유회 1호에 AI
칩 수출이 열리는 등 AI 인프라의
우호적인 뉴스가 좀 이어졌습니다.
그래서 이번 주는 CPI와 워시의장
첫 의회 증원 대형 은행과 TSMC
실적까지 하반기 방향을 가음할 재료가
좀 몰려 있고요. 높아진 실적 기대를
기업들이 실제 숫자로 증명하는지
확인해 봐야 되겠습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 어, 신고가 종목들이 좀
어, 업종들이 좀 갈려 있는데 좀
언급해 주실 내용이 혹시 좀
있습니까?
>> 어, 그 산업 쪽이랑 그 헬스케어
쪽에 신고가가 올라와 있는데요. 어,
좀 변동성이 그렇게 크지 않아서
이슈는 따로 전이된게 없고요.
>> 음. [목을 가다듬음] 알겠습니다.
저는 어 몇 번 말씀드렸는데요.
앞에이 모닝 블리프 시작할 때 맨
처음 10년물 국채 금리 그리고 달러
인덱스 유가 이것들을 좀 보는데 어
지금 10년물 국채는 4.5 5
레벨에서 좀 잘 쉽게 안 떨어지는 거
같고 유가도 지금 70불 초반까지
가파르게 이제 떨어졌는데
>> 거기에서는 추가적으로 크게 다시
60불 완전 초반으로 다시
내려온다든지 뭐 시체가 좀 있지
않을까 하는 생각이 좀 들어서 시장은
계속해서 어 단기 이슈에 따라서 지금
등락을 반복하고 있는 것 같은데
그럼에도 불구하고 이제 주요 지수를
보면 다우 SMP 500 나스닥 전일
다 소폭 좀 올랐습니다만 전부 다
그래도 어 최근 1, 2주 부지는
이제 만해를 한 것 같고 특히나이
나스닥이나 SP 500 기준으로는
대부분 다 만해하고 신고가 나는
종목들도 이제 조금씩 나오는 거
같습니다. 어 밑에 쭉 보시면 이제
종목들마다 좀 갈리는데요. 오늘 어
[콧방귀] 미국 시황이나 전 아
간밤에 있었던 한국 시장의 야간
선물도 중요하겠으나 지금 미국 시장이
선물이 좀 약세를 보이고 있어서 한국
시장 초반에는 그런 부분을 [콧방귀]
좀 반영하지 않을까 하는데 어 결국은
이제 중동 전쟁이 그 유가 그리고
금리 이런 곳에 얼마나 영향을
미치느냐가 한국 시장에 그 영향을
미치는 연결 고리가 될 텐데 이번에도
유가는 크게 움직이지 않을 것이라고
예상하는지 준혁 중에 물어보고
시작하겠습니다.
[웃음]
>> 네.
보겠습니다.
>> 네. [콧방귀] 점점 제가 한 말들에
대해서 책임을 줘야 될 것 같은 그런
상황들이 이어지고 있어서 부담이
굉장히 많이 됩니다. 유가는 현재로
봤을 때는 어 반응을 좀 해 주고는
있는 거 같습니다. 근데 주말 사이에
주말 사이에 똑같이 이제 미국이
이란을 공습하는 그런 대응의 어 그런
공격 절차를 그니까 공격을 하는 그런
과정 속에서는 유가가 등락을 계속
반복했었거든요. 그래서 실제로공격을
했을 때는 과다가 아 그 공격의
실체를 파악하거나 아니 공격의 강도
공격의 타겟 위치 정도를 파악하고
나서는 다시 한번 유가 급락하는 그런
모습을 보인 바 있습니다. 우선
이것도 이제 유가 선물이 막 그
오픈한지 얼마 안 돼서 지금 굉장히
큰 반응을 약간 주말사에 있던 반응을
다시 한번 어 반영하는듯한 모습을
보이긴 하지만요. 제가 생각할 때는
가장 자산의 가격도 그렇고 어 유가의
가격도 그렇고 어 좀 회복력이 좀
좋아진 모습은 훨씬 있다라고 말씀드릴
수가 있을 것 같고 유가도
다시 회복하는 모습을 보이지 않을까
하는 생각을 굉장히 많이 하고
있습니다. 그래서 이번에 제가 좀
주말에 보면서 음물론적인 얘기일 수도
있지만 들리는 얘기가 트럼프가 이제
유가가 어느 정도 회복력을 가지고
나서부터는 시간을 좀 더 여유 있게
쓴다라는 말도 제가 많이 들었습니다.
그래서 어 원래는 유가가 실제로
공급량이 충격이 있기 때문에 그걸
저희가 어 트럼프가 유가가 박힐
때마다 조금 좀 주식 시장을
안정시키려고 하는 그런 발언들을 해
줬었는데 지금 같은 경우는 너무 지금
사람들이 그 주식 시장이 유가의
반응에 대해서 내성이 생겼다 보니까
어 조금 더 여유 있게 되지 조금 더
기다렸다야도 되지 왜냐면 이제 공급이
오히려 과잉되는 거 아니냐 이런
오히려 말이 나오고 있기 때문에 그런
거에 대해서 어 좀 트럼프가 어
시간을 좀 질질 끌면서 진행하고 있는
부분 아닌가 하는 생각을 하고
있습니다.음. 그래서이어서 말씀을
드리면 될까요? 네. 말씀을 드리면
가장자 가격 흐름도 나쁘지
않았습니다. 전쟁이 주말 내내에
이루졌고 금요일 날에도 사실 이제 어
주말에 있을 전쟁 전시 상황이 조금
더 악화될 수 있다. 그런 흐름들을
반영하면서 가장자 가격 한
6,000불 정도 대에서 거래가
됐었는데요. 어 지금 주말 사이 흐름
보시면 거의 64,000불
64,200불 500불이 정도
흐름에서 계속 위에 있었다라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다. 그래서 어 지정확의
리스크가 나오더라도 크게 반응하지
않은 모습 그리고 이전보다 반응의
폭이 훨씬 줄어든 정도를 확인하실 수
있을 것 같습니다. 그래서 지금
현재는 63,000불 정도거대에
거래가 되고 있지만 어 제한 사기에는
유가의 흐름이 점점 미매해져 가고
가고 있고 유가보다는 가장자산
시장에서의 충격은 훨씬 덜하다라고
말씀을 드릴 수가 있을 것 같습니다.
오른쪽에 비트코인 장기 차트 쪽
보시면 아직도 제가 말씀드린 200주
이평선을 위에서 잘 시키고 있기
때문에이 부분은 충분히 긍정적이다라고
말씀을 드릴 수가 있을 것 같고요.
늘어서 보시면 비트코인 피앤 그레드
인덱스 있습니다. 어 공포 구간에
26 정도를 기록하고 있다 정도
보시면 될 거 같고 어 비트코 효물
ETF 순위 순유출은 완전히
긍정적으로 바뀌진 않았지만 부정적인
추세는 조금 벗어난 것 같습니다.
그래서 목요일, 금요일 수준으로 봤을
때 -4년 정도가 어 유출되었고요.
어 지난 한 주간으로 봤을 때
200밀리 정도가 유입이 된 한
주였습니다.이 이 200밀리 큰
숫자는 아니지만 제가 말씀드린 것처럼
하락의 추세 그리고 유출세가 어
굉장히 크게 지속되던 그 추세를 어느
정도는 좀 벗어나서 좀 씌어가는
추세가 있지 않나 하는 어 느낌이
있었고 지난 한 주간 좀
타이밍적으로도 조금 이상했다라고
생각이 드는게 월요일 날에는 어
마이클 세일러가 비트코인을 굉장히
많이 매도한 것이 어 큰 화수가
되었었는데 그 바로이어서 트럼프가
가장자단 시장을 조건 좀 부업시켜
주는 그런 발언들과 다양한 그 규제
변화들로 어 비트코인 한 주 동안
ETF 순 유출이 유입이 조금
지속되지 않았나 그런 생각이
했었습니다. 어 서클이
통화 감독청으로부터 전국 신탁은행
설립을 승인 받았다라고 합니다.
그래서 서클 주가 흐름이 어 금요일
날 굉장히 많이 올랐다가 조금
밑꼬리를 달고 어 내려오는 모습이
있었는데요. 어 서클이이 어 서클
내셔널 트러스트라는 어 새로운 신탁
은행을 설립을 해서 보통의 지금 신탁
은행들고 JP번 볼스탠리 같이 어
실제로 신탁 업무들을 진행을 할 수
있다라고 합니다. 그래서 어 스테이블
코인을 결국에 발행하고 있는 업체로서
그 그런 어 회사인데 어 그런 신탁
은행을 어 설립할 수 있고 그걸
영업을 할 수 있는 그런 어 규제적인
부분에 훨씬 승인을 받았다 보니까 어
향후에 다른 밸루에이션 적으로 조금
더 어 프리미엄을 받을 수 있는
그리고 실내적으로도 좀 더 프리미엄
받을 수 있는 움직임이지 않나 이런
어 생각이 많이 들고요. 그래서 어
테더와 지금 경쟁을 본격적으로 많이
하고 있고 최근에는 오픈라는 새로운
스테이블 코인과 지금 경쟁을 하고
있는데 이런 부분이 좀 결정적으로
차이가 나고 서클이 밀고자 하는
방향이 무엇인지 조금 더 분명하게
드러나는 것 같습니다. 그래서 다른
업체들이 우리는 스테이블코인 시장에
어 점유를 뺏어올 거다라고 말하는 기
그 시간 동안에 서클은 지금
굉장히 전국적으로 그리고 글로벌리하게
그냥 어 규제적인 부분에서 많은 것을
뚫어놓고 있거든요. 유럽에서도 미카
법안을 뚫어놓고 뉴욕에서도 어 금융
서비스에서 규제 승인을 받은 가장 첫
번째 어 스테이블 코인 업체이고요.
그 영국이나 싱가포르 범유다 같은 어
그 지역에서도 라이선스 받고
아부다비나 캐나다 같은 데서도 규제를
이미 많이 뚫어놓고 있습니다. 그래서
서클이 가고자 하는 방향은 결국에
그냥 스테이블코인 발행사로서 는게
아니라 그냥 미국의 한 은행으로 어
또는 미국의 한 은행의 전략적인
파트너로서 역할을 하면서 어 좀 더
사업적으로 포트폴리오 다변해 다변화해
나가고 그리고 결정적으로 어 마지막
최종 그 엔드 유저한테는 스테이블
코인을 발행해서 그걸 유통시킬 수
있는 어 그런 다양한 채널 그 다양한
규제를 좀 열어두고 있는 어 그런
변화로 가고 있다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 그래서 어 지금 서클이
주가 흐름이 굉장히 등락폭이 큽니다.
오른쪽 보시면 주가 차트가 올락일락
많이 하는데요. 지금은 사실
비트코인의 시장 그리고 비트코인의
가격 움직임에 조금 민감하게 움직이는
편이기는 합니다. 그래서 2월에
비트코인 시장이 전쟁 이후에 굉장히
좋았을 때 어 그때 같이 상승하는
모습을 보여줬다가 다시 하락하는 모습
이렇게 보여주고 있고 최근 오픈 어
이슈 때문에 급락하는 모습
보여줬었는데 이런 식으로 규제
관련해서 많은 것을 뚫어놓다 보면
나중에 조금 비트곤 가격이 좀
올라와서 어 상승하는 흐름 흐름 속에
있을 때는 서클의 어 규제적인 실
규제적인 레버리지가 좀 많이 발생할
수 있다라는 생각은 개인적으로
했습니다. 그래서 뭔가 다른 스테이블
코인 발행사들이 안 될 때 어 서클이
이런 것들이 가능하기 때문에 어 좀
확치고 나가는 모습을 보여 주지
않을까 하는 생각을 했고 그 오픈
컨솔 시험 형태로 많은 기업들이
모여서 스테이블 코인을 만들고 있는
그런 형태로 요즘에 어 많이 시도가
이루어지고 있는데 오히려 이런 규제를
설립하는 규제를 승인받고 있는 서클의
움직임을 보면서 아 이런 것들이
서클과 오픈 USD 차이가 될 수
있겠다라는 생각을 했습니다. 왜냐면이
규제를 승인받고 서류를 제치하고 이런
것들 다 시간과 비용이 굉장히 많이
드는 건데 오픈 USD는 특히 다양한
기업들이 컨소시엄 형태를 모여서 이런
것들 진행한다. 그리고 이제 그 미국
내에만누 미국 내에 있는 기업만
진행하는게 아니라 다양한 국가에서의
기업들이 함께 지금 추진을 하고
있잖아요. 그러면 그 국가들마다의
규제 승인이 또 다 될 거고 그것을
미국에 다시 끌고 왔을 때 스테이블
코인 발행해서 유통할 때 또 다른 어
규제의 승인을 받아야 될 텐데 서클은
그런 부분에선 훨씬 레버리지가 있는
거 같다 이렇게 생각을 또 추가적으로
들었습니다. 어 밑으로 내려와서
보시면 로빈 우드가 요즘에 조금 어
조금 붐이 되고 있습니다. 리버리 그
첫 번째 왼쪽에 밑에 사진을 보시면
이더리움 브릿지 물량이 100밀리언을
돌파했다 이렇게 나와 있는 토큰
터미널의 자료가 있었는데요.이 이
브릿지라는 거는 제가 말씀드린 것처럼
어 그 블록체인이 여기 칸수를 이렇게
아파트 같이 위로 쌓인다고 말씀드린
적이 있습니다. 그래서 가장 밑에
베이스로 까이는게 L1이라고 하는
거고요. 그 위에 L2, L3 이렇게
하나씩 위로 쌓 쌓이는 건데 어쨌든
가장 밑에 있는 L1이라고 하는 그
체인을 바탕으로 해서 그 위에 앱같이
애플리케이션 같이 쌓인다라고 보시면
될 거 같거든요. 근데 로빈 우드
로비누드는 어 체인을 여기 L2
2층에다 쌓왔습니다. 그래서
1층에다가 어 이더리움을 뭐
100m년 정도의 물량을 묶어 두고
그거를 그대로 2층에다가 가져온다이
정도 흐름으로 보시면 되거든요.
기술적으로 굉장히 어려울 수 있는데
사실은 그냥 어 중복되지 않게 여기
있는 이더리움을 L1에 있는 이더리움
1층에 있는 이더리움을 2층으로
가져올 때 1층에도 이더리움이
100만 그 100m년 정도 있고
2층에도 이더리움이 100만
100m년 정도 있지 않게 1층에서는
없던 걸로지게 이렇게 묶어 두는
거고요. 어, 2층으로 가져와서
100밀리어는 물량을 어,
유통시키거나 아니면 뭐 가스비로
쓰거나 다양한 용토로 이게 쓰이게
되는게 브릿지라는 기술이다. 이렇게
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 어쨌든
기술적으로 그렇게 크게 중요하진 않고
어,로 그 로비누드라는 체인이 지금
어, 런칭을 하고 나서 지금 7월
1일부터 런칭을 하기 시작했는데
굉장히 빠른 성장세를 보여주고
있습니다. 그래서 오른쪽에 보시면
24시간 어 기준으로 나와 있는 어,
차트인데요. 로비노 체인이 거의 두
번째에 위치하고 있는 그런
흐름이다라고 보시면 될 거 같은데
이더 그 로비노두는 지금 민코인으로
굉장히 많이 뜨고 있습니다. 그래서
예를 들어서 어 저희가 정말 쓰잘데기
없는 어 저희가 쓰잘데이 없다고 말이
되는지 모르겠지만 쓰잘데이 없는 그런
코인들을 하나 상장을 해서 그 코인이
왜 재밌고 어 왜 사야 되고 이런
것들을 잘 프로모션 하게 된다라고
하면 거래량이 굉장히 많이 나오면
등락이 나오는 어 그런 흐름으로 지금
가고 있습니다. 그래서 그런 좀
멸려지고 있고 이더리움이 그 아
로비우드 체인이 그런 걸
위해서나타났다 이렇게 보시기보다는
그런 쪽으로도 지금 붐이 많이 되고
있고 어쨌든 새로운 시장이다 보고
새로운 거래소 어 이런 것들로 열렸다
보니까 그런 부분에 좀 부엄업이 많이
되고 있다 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 어 그리고 제가 이거이
블록체인 그 로빈드 체인을 가져온
이유는 로비누드 쪽에서도 앞으로이
체인 쪽에서 성장이 많이 일어나기
때문에 굉장히 좋다라고 말씀드릴 수
있지만 이더리움을 하나 말씀드리려고
가져온 건데요. 교 아까 말씀드린
것처럼 저가 어 이더리움의 스테이킹
물량이 굉장히 많아지고 있기 때문에
그니까 묶기는 물량이 굉장히 많아지고
있기 때문에 시장이 유통되는 어
이더리움의 분량이 점점점 줄어들고
있다 말씀을 드린 적이 한번
있었는데요.이 브릿지도 사실 동일한
내용입니다. 어 그래서이 이더리움이
실제로 유통되지 않는 량을 점점점
늘려가다 보니까 실제로 묶이는 양을
늘리다 보니까 어 이더리움이 시장에서
거래되고 있는 그 물량 자체는
수급상으로 굉장히 줄어들 수밖에 없는
그러니까 100밀만치 100밀
어치만큼의 이더리움이 그냥 유더리 그
유통량이 줄어졌다 이렇게 보시면
되거든요. 그래서 어 그런 부분들이
이더리움에도 긍정적인 효과가 날 수
있다. 그래서 만약에 이더리움이
로비노드 체인 때문에 올랐다라고
하면이 이유 때문에 그렇다라고
이해하시면 될 거 같아서 어
가져왔습니다. 이사입니다.
>> 감사합니다.요 표를 보다 보니까 어이
표의 맨 위에 오류 비트코인 장기
차트 요건 제가 확대해서 보니까
주봉인 거 같아요. 이게 주봉인데
보니까 지금 2주째
>> 어 여기서는 이게 한국식으로 표현이
돼 있으니까 초록 세기와의 양봉인
건가요?
>> 네. 네. 네. 초록색인봉.
>> 그렇죠. 그러면 지금 2주 2주째
지금 양봉이 나고 있어요. 그래서
기술적으로 보면 이제 여기서 거래량만
실리면
>> 빠르게 이제 지지하면서 올라올 수
있는 것 같다는 생각이 좀 들었고.
음. 그리고 밑에 보면 맨 아래 아
맨 아래에서 두 번째 보시면 서클
주가는 요거는 또 미국 식으로 지금이
차트가 그려진 거 아닌가 싶어요.
이게 붉은색이면 음봉인 건가요?
>> 네. 네. 어, 둘 다 미국식. 네.
>> 네. 아 그러면 어 서클도 음봉이고
맨 오른쪽 위에 비트코인도
아 양봉 비트코인 양봉 어 그러네요.
아 죄송합니다. 제가 헷갈렸어요. 그
밑에 보면은 이제 계속 말씀 주신
것처럼 뭔가 이제 규제나 아니면은
제도적인 차원에서 해계 무의를 준다
또는 한 단계 앞으로 나간다 이런
이슈들이 나올 때마다 어 계속해서 좀
주가는 좀 반응을 하는데
>> 그게 아직은 조금 이제 미래가 좀
남아 있다 보니 어 위에 꼬리를 좀
달고 달고 그러는 거 같습니다.
그리고 어 왼쪽 아래 이더리움 브릿지
물량 여기에서 제가 아까 하나 좀
놓친 게
>> 네
>> 어 이해를 좀 했어요. 이더리움에
L1, L2, L3도 이해하고 브릿도
어떤 개념인지 이해를 했는데 요게
로빈트하고 연결되는 부분은 아,
로비누트가 어, 이더리움 1층에 있는
이더리움을 바탕으로
>> 음, [목을 가다듬음]
>> L2에다, 2층에다 뭔가 애플리케이션
쌓았다, 만들었다 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 그걸 런칭해서 사람들이
지금 이용을 하고 있는데
>> 그 이더리움을이
로비드가 만든 L2층에 있는 앱에서
사용하기 위해서 이제 이더리움을
1층에서 가져가야 되거든요. 그래서
1층에 있는 이더리움은 없다 치고
2층에서 이제 이더리움을 사용하고
있는 거다라고 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 그래서 로빈 우드가 어
L2를 새로 오픈했습니다. 2층에
있는 새로운 어플리케이션 오픈을 한게
7월 1일 날 나온 뉴스이고요. 그
이후부터 실제로 출시를 해서 굉장히
빠른 성장세를 보이고 있는데 어
1층에는 이더리움을 2층에 있는
로빈후드 앱으로 가져가서 사용하고
있다. 그렇기 때문에 로빈 후드가
어이 론칭하고 나서 굉장히 잘 되고
있기 때문에 로빈 후드도 굉장히 좋고
어 그리고 1층에는 이더리움은
수급상으로 이더리움에 있는 물량이
점점 줄어들었기 때문에 이더리움에도
좋다이 이런 취지로 말씀을 드리긴
했습니다.
>> 이해했습니다. 조금 더 공부를 해야
완벽하게 이해를 할 수 있을 것
같아서 계속 공부 좀 해 보겠습니다.
아 일부 여기서 마치려고 합니다.
오늘 월요일이라 계속 신부장님이 또
이런저런 기업 관련한 뉴스들을 올려
주고 계시는데요. 감사드립니다.
그리고 김민주 님도 계속해서 기업들
수출 관련한 디테일들을 좀 올려 주고
계시는데 어 쭉 한번 저도 자리에서
읽어 보도록 하겠습니다. 오늘
월요일이라 2부에서는 이제
밸루에이션까지 봐야 하기 때문에
내용이 좀 길 텐데요. 어 2부도
함께 해 주시길 바라면서 1부도 함께
해 주셔서 감사하다는 말씀 드리고
마치도록 하겠습니다. 오늘 월요일
7월 13일 1분은 여기서 마치도록
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
>> [음악]
>> เฮ
안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 여정을
체슬리 투자 전문과 함께 체슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 7월 13일 즐거운
월요일 2부 순서 시작하도록
하겠습니다. 자 월요일이라서
자료가 아주 많은데
다들 춤을 잘 보내셨죠? 예예
>> 폭염 와 어제부터는 정말
선풍기 에어컨 없으면 자기 힘들죠
[목을 가다듬음]
포겸이 시작되긴 했는데 한 달 정도
예 고생한 거 듣긴 한데
자 어
미국 시장 자료
우리 최부 사장님 이제 준비하신 자료
한번 보겠습니다. 예. 어,
최근 2주간 주요 흐름을 보면은
SMP500이나 나스닥 그리고 다운
이런 주요 지수는
고점에서 거래가 되고 있고요.
반면에 필반 지수는 한 11% 정도
빠진 상황인데
어떤 변화가 있는지 주 종목별로 한번
살펴보면은 대략적으로
어 섹터의 확산이나 그리고 순환매
그리고 종목 차별화가 이렇게 섞여서
진행되고 있는듯한 느낌입니다. 그래서
주요 종목별로 보면은 최근 2주간
흐름을 보면은
지난주는 건강 관리하고 필수비 이런
좀 방어 섹터가 어 약세였고요.
그리고 빅테크 가운데 메타하고 브로드
보드컴, 엔비디아, 테슬라, 아마존
이런 종목들이 2주 연속 강세를 보인
반면에 어 구글이나 마이크로소프트는
좀 락하는 모습이었습니다.
그리고 좀 전에 방어 섹터 중에서
코카콜라, 일라일리, 존슨 존슨,
코스코, 어, 비자 이런 것들이 좀
약세였고 구체적으로
등교를 보면은 메타가 최근 2주간에
어, 첫 주는 5.9%, 두 번째
주는 14.8% 올랐고. 그
브로드컴이 아, 지난주에 11%
올랐고 N비디아가
1.2% 8.3% % 연속
상승했습니다.
그리고 AMD가 한 7.7% 정도
상승했고요. 지난주에
모건 스탠리 3.9% 그리고 테슬라도
각각 3.6% 3.6% 정도 그냥
두간 상승했고요. 애플도 두간 상승.
그리고 쭉 가다 보면은 이제 아마존도
두 주 상승했습니다. 마이크론이 어
2주 전에 13.8% 하락했는데
아 지난주에 한 0.4% 4% 정도
상승한데 그쳤고요. 그리고 어플라이드
머티리얼 램리서치 어 빠진 다음에
상승폭이 좀 이약했습니다. 그리고
구글이 M7 중에서 2주 전에
6.7% 7% 상승했다가 지난주에는
좀 어 쉬었고요. 그다음에
마이크로소프트 M7 중에서 4.7%이
주전에 상승한 다음에 1.4% 정도
하락했고
말씀드렸던 대로 방어 섹터 중에서
1라리 존슨 존슨 비자 포스코는 어
지난주에 좀 하락하는 그런 모습이
관찰됐습니다. 그래서 M7 중에서도
아 특히 어 강한 어 종목들이 최근
2주간 나타났는데 그중에 이제 어
메타나 Nv디아나 그리고 테슬라 애플
정도였고요.
그리고 약한 종목은 M7 중에서 약한
종목은 구글라고
그리고 마이크로소프트 정도였고
최근에 많이 빠졌던 반도체 쪽에 어
상승폭 회복력은 좀 다소 약한
편이었습니다. 해서 아 이번 주에
실정 나오는 ASML이나
그리고
ASML하고 TSMC 어 요런
부분들이 모멘텀을 다시 불어넣어 줄지
살펴봐야 될 것 같고요. 밑에 이제
차트 보시면은 M7이 어
바닥 찍고 최근 2주간 올라가는
모습이고
라스닥 바이오 ETF인 IBBQ는
최근 일주간 좀 하락하는 모습이고
IGB는 어 종목별로 그 차별화가
계속 심하다 보니까 어 상승 추세
자체가 조금 둔패입니다. 그리고 소스
반토체 ETF는 빠졌다가 지난주에 한
2% 정도 상승하는 모습이 그래서
섹터의 확산이나 순환매 차별화 요런
부분들에 좀 주한점을 두고 봐야 될
것 같습니다.
SK 하이닉스하고 SK 하이닉스
ADR 어 지난주 금요일 날
SK하이닉스
ADR이 어 상장이 되면서 과연 어떤
흐름이 나타날지 이번 주에 좀 위추가
주목되는데요. 마이콘 테크놀로지하고
좀 어 비교를 해 봤고 그리고 대만에
TSMC하고도
비교를 해 봤는데
현재 달러 표시 그 SK하이닉스의
12개월 4드 EPS가 273불 정도
되고
ADR 주가가 168불. 근데 이게
10대 1 비율이기 때문에 어 계산을
해 보면은 SK하이닉스 ADR이
PR이 6. 어 1호배에 지금 거래가
되고 있습니다.
그래서 어 본주하고
그지 가격을 따져 보자면은
15.5% 정도의 어 괴리가 발생을
하고 있는 상황이고요.
마이크론 테크날로지하고를
비교를 해 보면은 좀 전에
SK이닉스의 ADR이 6.25배인
반면에 마이크론이 6.96배를
96배를 기록을 하면서
마이크론이 여전히 SK하이닉스 ADR
대비로 프리미엄을 받고 있고요.
한편 그 SK하이닉스 본주의 PR
한국에 상장되 있는 본주의 PR은
5.52배로
어 ADR 대비 상대적 평가를 받고
있습니다. 그렇기 때문에 이제 어
가격적으로는 15.5%의 어 괴리가
발생되고 있는데이 15.5%의 %의
괴리가 정당한 것인지 아니면 이대로
어 축소될 것인지 도학대가 될 것인지
요거에 이제 어느 정도 관심사 때
미리 비슷하게 어 대만의 TSMC가
미국의 ADR로 상장되 있는 상황에서
비교를 해 보자면은 대만의 TSMC가
어
본추에서는 아 저 대만 본토에서 어
살려면은 좀 복잡하다고 입니다.
그래서
미국 투자자들은 본주보다도
그 미국에 상장된 ADR를 더 어 더
ADR을 더 선호한다고 보면 될 거
같고요. 그렇게 된 이유가 외우 기관
투자자가 본주 사려면 좀 절차가
복잡하다는 점. 그리고 대만의 자본
유출에 대한 규제가 있다는 점.
그리고 대만의 그 가격 제한폭이
플러스 마이너스 10%로 좀 작다는
점. 그리고 상대적으로 짧은 거래
시간도 좀 장애가 된다고 하고요.
대만은 오전 9시에서 오후 1시
30분까지
하루 4시간 30분 정도 어 거래가
된다고 합니다. 그리고 공매도 규제가
또 좀 있다고 하고요. 그래서
TSMC의 경우 본주하고 ADR
괜리가 현재 15.7%인데 7%인데
비슷하게 그 SK 하이닉스 본주하고
SK 하이닉스 ADR하고의 어 괴리얼
게리율도 한 15.5% 5% 정도 어
차이가 나고 있는 상황입니다. 근데
TSMC에 비해서 SK 하이닉스 거래
제약이 좀 상대적으로 작다는 걸
감안할 때 SK 하이닉스 ADR하고
본조i 개리는 대원보다 조금 낮아지지
않을까 작아지지 않을까 어 요런
생각을 조금 해 봤습니다. 그래서 어
낮아진다는 건 뭐 어 그 우리나라
본주가 좀 더 상승할 수도 있고
SK하이닉스 ADR이 좀 하락할 수도
있고 이렇게 되는 건데 그 추위는 어
지켜봐야 될 것 같습니다.
어 이번 주에 ASML하고 TSMC
실적이 나오기 때문에 잠깐 프리뷰를
해 보면은 어 ASM L의 어
회계년도
어 26년어 2분기 실적이라고 보시면
될 거 같고요.
매출이 10.1빌리언 달러. Yyy로
16.2%
아 증가할 걸로 보고 있고 영업
이익률 34.7%를 7%를 기록할
걸로 시장에서는 보고 있습니다.
그다음 분기는 36.9%로 좀
이익률이 늘어날 걸로 보고 있고요.
EPS 같은 경우는
9.82달러로
아
저기
분기를 헷갈렸는데 7.82달러로
17.1% 정도 늘어날 걸로 보고
있습니다. 그다음 분기가
9.82달러로 53.4% 4% 정도
늘어날 거 보이고 있어요. 가장
[콧방귀] 중요한 거니 뭐 실적이
숫자는 이게 수주 받아 가지고 수주를
매출로 반영하는 거기 때문에 그
시간차가 있는 어 숫자라서
좀 위로 서프라이즈도 하고 밑으로
서프라이즈도 하고 하는데 그 수주
추위 관련된 어 코멘트가 좀 중요할
것 같습니다. 해서 아 최근에 그
종합 반도체 회사들이 계속해서 그
증설에 나설 수 있다는 시그널을
보이면서 그 부분이 좀 긍정적으로 어
보이고 있고요.
아 주가는 고점 대비 한 9.7%
최근에 하락을 했고요. PR은
41.1배 거래가 되고 있습니다.
어 TSMC 실적을 보면 실적
프리뷰를 보면은 매출은 39.3빌리언
3빌리언 달러로 YY로 29.7%
정도 증가할 걸로 예상이 되고 있고
영업 이익률이 58점 6%를 기록할
걸로 보고 있습니다. EPS는 어
0.75달러로 7달러로 YY 50%
정도로 예 그 어 증가할 걸로 보고
있고 지금 케파 쪽에서 TSMC가
병목을 겪고 있기 때문에 어 케펙스
가이던스를 어떻게 주느냐에 따라서
밑에 장비주들도 같이 움직일 가능성이
있어 보이고요.
현재 2분기에 어 케팩스는
13.4빌리언
달러로 예상되고 있고 3분기 케스는
13.8 1년 달러로 예상되고
있습니다. 근데 지난번에
실적 발표할 때 장기 케펙스 계획을
이번 분기 실적 발표 때 얘기해
준다고 했기 때문에 시장의 관심은
실적도 중요한데 캠팩스 쪽으로 가지
않을까라고 생각을 하고 있습니다.
아 주가는 고점 대비 9.1% 1%로
하락을 했고요.
PER 같은 경우는 어
21.09급에까지
좀 내려온 상황입니다.
그래서이 두 회사의 어 실적
관련해서 반도체 섹터의 모멘텀이
어떻게 반영되는지 좀 살펴볼 필요가
있을 것 같습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 네.
그 하이넥스
주가랑
어
하이닉스 AD랑
뭐 저는 그렇게 보거든요. 네이버
보면 하이닉스 ADR에 대한 시총이
나와요.
>> 예. 이 시총이 딱 보면 얘네들
계산이 딱 돼서 어 [콧방귀] 얼마로
나오냐면 1조 7천
어 우리나라 걸로 1787조
>> 예
>> 1787조 나오고 국내는 지금 있는
그대로 1553조
>> 음
>> 예 7천억 정도 1550
3조 7,000원
그래서 그냥 시총으로
>> 나눠 버리거든
>> 예 시총으로 나눠 버리 그니까
15.04. 아, 그렇다.
>> 이게 근데 이제 환율 차이가 있다고
실시간으로 이제 환율이 바뀌다 보면
예.
>> 지금 여기서는 이제 1498.5원을
적용했고
>> 예.
>> 또 환율이 살짝 좀 오르면 1504원
뭐 이렇게 환율이 바뀌면 국내가
오히려 더 싸지죠. 환율이 올라가면.
>> 네. 그런 것들로
밸류에이션 비교해 보시고 싶은 분들은
그냥 네이버에 나오는 시총 가지고서
해 보면 되고 그래서 TSNC 같은
경우에 그동안에 한 30년 동안에
그냥 계속이 프리미엄이 계속
유지됐었더라고요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 그 정도의 차이는 있지만 어떤 때는
20%도 넘었던 적도 있고요.
>> 네.
>> 지금은 한 15.7% 한 7% 정도가
프리미엄 유지가 됐 되고 있습니다.
자, 그리고 어 밸루에이션으로 넘어가
보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 예, 알겠습니다.
어, 지난주 SNP 500 어
1주간에 1.2% 정도 상승을
했고요. 12개월 포워드 EPS는
0.3% 정도 상향 중정됐습니다.
YTD로 10.7%가 7%가
상승을 했는데 어 간만에 두 자릿수
상승을 SP 500에서 보는 거
같고요. 12개월 4드 EPS는
19.6%가 상용 주정됐습니다.
7월 10일 기준으로 P은
20.37배 37배 PBR은
5.76배 거래가 되고 있고요.
종목별로 보면은 좀 전에 말씀드렸듯이
빅테크 쪽에서 좀 견조했습니다. 물론
어 종목에 따라서 약간씩 차별하은
있지만 Nv디아가 주간 기준으로
8.3% 상승했고요. 애플 2.2%
그리고 구글 -0.8% 마이크로소프트
-1.4%
아마존 1.1% 그리고 브로드컴
11.0. 0% 메타가 14.8%
테슬라 3.6% 일라이리 -2.1%
마이크론 0.4% 그리고 어 버크
-2.8%
AMD가
아 7.7%입니다. 7%입니다.
이익 보시면은 특별히 뭐 크게 상향
조정된거나 하향 조정된 거가
안 보이고요.
어 마이크로 테크놀로지가 1.2%
사용 조정됐고 AMD가 1.6%
사용됐습니다.
보시면은 Nvide디아가 20배
밑에서 거래되고 있는데
19.7배고요.
애플이 33.3배 구글 24배 마이크
아 마이크로소프트 19.7배
아마존 22.5배
브로드컴 23.7배
메타가 16.2배 아 테슬라
183.4배
일라릴리 29.3배
마이크론 6.9배
버크스에 24.9배에 900배에
거래되고 있습니다. 조금씩 올라서
피도 조금씩 어 올라와 있는 그런
상황입니다.
섹터흐름 보면은 IT 반도체
커뮤니케이션이 상승을 했고요. 나머지
필수비제 헬스케어 산업제 유틸리티 어
이런 경제 섹터들이 하락을 했습니다.
어 12월 4드 EPS는 어 계속
무상향하고 있는 상황이고요. 이번
주에 매크로 관점에서 CPI하고
PPI가 나오는데 CPI가 3.8%
정도로 나올 걸로 예상이 되고 있는데
한 1주 전엔가 한 3.9%에서 조금
더
>> 계속 떨어지네요.
>> 낮아졌습니다. 예.
>> 그래서 시장이
조금 너무 막해보고 있는 건가? 두
높이가 너무 낮아진 건가는 생각도
들고요. 어, 클리블랜드 연원에서는
아직 3.9%로 보고 있습니다.
그래서 시장이 조금 그 이거에 대해서
낮게 나올 걸로 더 상대적으로 더
낮게 보고 있는 거 같고요. PPI가
6.2%로
어 예상이 되고 있고요. 그리고 소매
판매시간대 서베이가 예상이 되고
있습니다. 소매 판매 같은 경우는
0.3%가 3%가 전월 대비 증가할
걸로 보고 있는데 이게 명목 그
금액이기 때문에 가격이 조금씩
떨어지면은 가격에 영향을 받아서
증가율로 떨어지게 돼 있습니다. 근데
또 유가 주요서에서 쓰는 금액 자체가
같은 양이라고 하더라도 가격 자체가
낮아졌기 때문에 그 부분이 영향을
미치지 않았을까라고 생각을 하고 있고
일단 나오면 알 것 같습니다. 어
기업 실적 보면은 이번 주부터
본격적으로 기업 실적 발표가 있는데
아 금융주부터 CT 그룹 JP모건
웰스프하고 뱅커메니카가
있고요. IT 기업 중에서는 ASML
TSM가 있습니다.
미국제 10년물하고 기대 인플레이션
장다극기면차 하일드 스프레드 보시면은
미국제 10년물은 어 4.56%로
8b가 지난주에 상승을 했고요.
2년물은 7bp가 상승한
4.21%입니다.
장단기금차는 35bvp고요.
기대 인플레이션은 2bp 상승한
2.25% 실질 금리는 6bp 상승한
2.30%
하일드하고 하일드 스프레드는
지난주에 어 하일드가 1bp 상승한
6.99% 99% 하일드 스프레드는
6bp에 하락한 2.69%
그래서 금리가 약간씩 좀 레벨업
되면서 어 우리가 많이 보는 미국제
10년물이 4.5%를 넘어서
4.56%를
기록하고 있고요 부분은 계속 어 정신
압방 요인으로 작용하지 않을까
싶습니다.
유가 보시면은 아 지난주에 3.9%
상승한 71.4불이었고요.
4불이었고요. 부리가 1% 상승한
6.23불. 그리고 미국의 천연가스가
9.4% 하락한 2.94불이었는데
유럽 천연가스는
지정학적 이슈가 좀 부각되면서
7.6% 상승한 48.8유로를
기록했습니다.
어 외한 시장 보면은 달러 인덱스가
0.1% 상승한 100.5를 고를
기록했고요.
달러 원 환율이 1,500원 밑으로
내려갔습니다. 1499.1원을
이렇게 있고요. 주간 기준으로
1.97% 하락했습니다.
유로 달러 같은 경우는 1유로당
0.2% 하락한 1.14일 달러를
기록했고요.
달러엔 N 같은 경우는 0.2%
상승은 1달러당 161.7회를 7엔을
기록했습니다. 그래서
유로하고 엔치가
좀 하락했고요.
원화 가치는 2% 정도 상승을 한
그런 한 주였습니다.
아 코스피 주가하고 밸루에이션
보시면은 어 최근 일주에 코스피가
7.6% 6% 하락했고요.
12개월 포드 EPS는 1.8% 상향
주정됐습니다.
YTD로 어 77.4%
상승을 했고 12개월 4드 EPS는
174.3%가
상형 조정됐습니다.
7월 10일 기준으로 코스피은
6.54배를
4배를 기록하고 있고 PBR은
2.1배를 기록하고 있습니다. 상승률
보시면은 어 대형주 위주로 좀 하락이
컸는데 삼성전자가 7.9%
하락했고요. 하이닉스 -10.1%
S계수기어 -11.3% 삼성전기
-20% 현대차 -7% LG엔솔
-10%
삼성생명 -11%
삼성 바이오 -1.8% 8% 삼성물산
-9.7%
현대 중공 -12.7%입니다.
7%입니다.
이익 아 이익 보시면은 삼성전자
SK닉스가 각각 4.2% 1.1%
상향 조정됐고요. 나머지는 뭐 큰
변환 없고 아 삼성 전기가 4.2%
정도 상향 조정됐습니다.
아 보시면 삼성전자가 5.0%
하이닉스가 5.5% 5.5배
SK게가 4.4배
삼성 전기가 57.900까지
내려왔습니다. 어 현대차 9.9배,
LGN 솔 88.3배 삼성생명
18.2배 삼성 바이오 31.9배
삼성물산 20.9배 현대중공업
15.7배
신한지주 8.5배를
기록하고 있습니다.
어 국내 금리 보시면은 국내 금리도
한 국고치 10년물 기준으로 3b
상승한 4.23%를 기록했고요.
3년물은 2bp 상승한 3.77%
장기 금리차는 46b를 기록하고
있습니다. 어 투자자금은
12.8조가
지난주에 감소했고
119.9조를 9조를 기록했습니다.
신용자도 한 1조 1천억 정도 감소한
36.6조를 기록했고요.
주관 1평균 거래대금도 6.6조
감소한 43.5조를 5조를
기억했습니다. 그래서 지난주에는 증시
주변 자금이 증시에 좀 영향을 받아서
그런지
대체로 트레택 특금이나 신용자라든지
주간 일평균 거래대금이 대체로
감소하는 어 그런 상황이었습니다.
이번 주는 매크로 지표 쪽에서 어
물가 지표하고요. 그리고
기업별로는 아, 금융주 실적 발표나
ASML, TSMC 실적 발표를
주목해서 보면 좋을 것 같습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 네. [목을 가다듬음] 투자자
예탁금이 많이 줄었네요.
>> 예, 많이 줄었습니다.
>> 음.
줄은 이렇게 줄은 이유가 아유 잘
모르겠습니다.
>> 주셔서 적금이 줄은 이유는 주식을
많이 사면서 줄은 거 아니에요?
>> 주식을 많이 사면서 줄 수도 있고
아니면 돈이 빠져나갔을 수도 있고요.
>> 그러니까 둘 중에 하난데
>> 예
>> 선구 매니저는 어떻게 생각해요? 투자
있거
>> 어 섞긴 결과라고 했는데 그 지난 한
주 동안에 개인들이 4조원 좀 넘게
주식을 못 했거든 그런 영향도 분명히
있지 않을까요?음
>> 최근에 외국인이
연초 이후 거의 200조 팔았잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 음. 그 한 달 사이에 얼마 전에
148조 뭐 160조 이러다가 최근에
거의 200조까지 올라왔거든요.
>> 그걸 그 결국은 누가 샀나 보면
>> 네. 개인이 바다가 쓸 거니까
>> 개인이 한 달 동안에 32조원 정도
치했습니다. 주식
>> 그죠? 어 결국 이제 떨어지는
어 주식을 이제 떨어질 때 많이
사시다 보니까 어 [콧방귀] 결국
투자자 예금에서 물론 빠져나온 것도
있긴 한데 그 하겠지만 많이 사서
그렇고 최근에 또 많이 올라올 때는
외국인이 또 공격적으로 살 때는
그런데 많이 몸 머니 뭐뭐가 많이
일어났었죠. 은행에서
>> 은행에서 많이 왔었고
>> 그동안에 계속 올라가기만 해 가지고
좀 살 기회가 없다가 이번에 좀
떨어질 때 공격적으로 사신 거 같은데
지금 60 이평선이 좀 깨져 있다
보니까 62평이면 최근 3개월 동안에
어 주식 사신 분들은 거의 다
물렸다고 보면 그래서 요즘 출심리가
조금 많이 악화돼 있다라고 느껴지는게
뭐 최근에 들어온 분들 3개월 동안
주식 들어온 분들은 평균적으로 이제
다 물렸다 보면 되고 뭐 대형주든
소형주든 그죠. 뭐 대형주 차트도
무너지고 소형주 차트도 무너진
상황에서 더 무너지고 이러다 보니까
어 최근에 좀 들어오신 분들
입장에서는 좀 약간 악뜨거하면서
놀 좀 놀라셨을 거요.
>> 자 그런
>> 코스피 지수가 SMP 500보다 더
높았었잖아요.
>> 그렇죠. 맞네. 예. 아 낮아졌네요.
>> 낮아졌습니다.
>> 7476이고 보스피는
SMP 500은
>> 757호입니다.
>> 7575
>> 예
>> 이제 볼 만하겠네요. 여기서 어떻게
앞서관이 지수건이에요 그습니다.
주말에 별주하는데
햄버거님이
>> 뭐 얘기하다가
감히 뭐 감히 뭐 국내 주식이 뭘
해서 뭘 그랬다고 이런 얘기를
>> 음
>> 비슷한 얘기를 했던게 기억이 나는데
정확한 얘기는 뭔지 모르겠지만
9,385까지
갔다가 지금 고수피는 고점 대비
-2.35 335 요렇게 기록을 하고
있습니다.
자, 그러면 어 국내 시장으로 넘어가
보도록 하겠습니다.
네, 금요일 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
코스피 지수 2.5%
상승으로 마감을 했었고요. 코스닥
시장이 굉장히 좋았었는데 5% 이상
급등세를 기록을 하면서 마감했습니다.
어, 수급적으로 봐 주시면 개인
추하자 7,억 대도가 있었고요. 반면
외국인도 어 외국인도 마찬가지로 한
3,억 대도가 나왔습니다. 기관에서
매수세가 좀 강하게 유입되는데요.
이거일 연속 혹수 매수입니다.
금요일장 1조 넘게 매수세가
유입이됐고 메인 선물 쪽에선
7,억이량 매도 나왔습니다.
투자자별 매매 동향으로 가서 보면
외국인 투자자 삼성전자를
매수했습니다. 1900억 대수세가
유입이 됐었고요. 그 외에는
삼성전기, 전자 우선주, SK
스qu어, 현대차, 현대 로템,
네이버 등을 매수했습니다. 외국인
매도에는 하이닉스 1조 7,억 대도가
있었고요. 그 외에는 대덕 전자,
원익, IPS, PSK, VM,
테스, 이수페타시스, 파두 등을
매도를 했습니다. 외국인 쪽에서
반도시 소부장이 금을 많이 강했었는데
거기에 대한 차익 실현들이 좀 많이
나왔던 거 같고요. 기간 매수에는
삼성전자 SK닉스 조정 합산에서 1조
넘게 매수세가 유입이었고 그 외에는
원익 IPS, PSK, 대덕 전자,
위스페타시스 등을 매수했습니다. 기간
매도에는 삼성전기, LG 이노텍,
SK 스퀘어, 현대 로템, 하나 에로
등을 매도를 했었고요.
52주 신고가 총 여섯 종목이
나왔는데 코스피에서 KB 금융, 신한
지주, 금모 타이어, 한성 기업 등이
신고가였고요. 코스닥에서는 인피니티
헬스케어가 신고가 한 종목이
있었습니다.
자, 하이닉스는 외국인 매도가 지난주
금요일에도 나왔었고 어, ADR
상장되면 저렇게 15% 정도
프리미엄을 붙을 걸 알고 있었을 건데
왜 팔았을까 그런 생각도 좀 들게
나고요. 그리고 또 15% 이제
올라서 거래되는 걸로 이제 확정이
되고 나서 어, 그런 생각이
들더라고요. 외국인 입장에서 이번에
하이닉스 ADR 공무 그 사실 한
6조 정도 또
>> 네
>> 할 때는 어 TSMC 사례 보면 어
무조건 먹는 거니까이 그 ADR
가격이
그 하이넥스 본주 가격으로 그 평균내
가지고 태운 거잖아요.
>> 예. 그리고 실제로 미국에 성장하면
그 본주 대비해서는 15% 정도
프리미엄은 붙을 거니까
>> 어떻게 보면 그런 거에 대한 퀀터
분석이 되어 있었던 외국인 해체펀드는
얘네들 입장에서는 무조건 지름만 먹는
거다.
>> 없구나 그런 생각이 들자.
>> 예. 그래서 무조건 이제 청약에
참가를 했을 거 같고 그렇기 때문에
일곱 배에서 뭐 열배 뭐 이렇게
대금이 몰렸다고 하더라고요. 예.
지금 실제로 그 SK 하이닉스를
가지고 있었던 어 ETF 일부
ETF에서 또 청약이 들어가서 오늘
보니까 어 SK 하이닉스 ADR이
들어왔더라고요.
>> 어 근데 그 기비중이 좀 미미합니다.
왜냐면 청약 경쟁률이 굉장히 강했던
거를 거기에서 이제 알 수
있겠더라고요.
자, 그리고 외국인은 삼성전자와 전기
전자 우선 중 SK 스퀘어 또 사서
자, 주요 종목도 동약 한번 쭉
보겠습니다.
네. 반도체 섹터 먼저 보면 대형
반도체는 삼성전자는 상승한 반면에
하이닉스는
약권 정도로 마감을 하면서 조금
아쉬운 모습이 이어졌고요. 반도체
소부장이 강한 반등세를 보여줬는데
HPSP가 13% 가량 급등세를
보여줬고요.
최근에 좀 많이 빠지기도 했었습니다.
그 외에는 리노궁 뭐 이오테크 원익
IPS 두산테스나 등이 또 강한 상세
보였고 아래 기판 쪽도 좋았습니다.
대덕 전자 8% 이수페타가 11%
급등세를 보였고요. 금요일장에서는
상대적으로 좀 장비주들이
어 소부장 다른 종목보다는 좀 강하게
올랐었던 거 같습니다. IT 섹터에선
삼성 전기가 6%대 반등에 성공을
했고요. 확실히 이전보다는 주가
상승세가 조금 둔화되는 모습이
나타나고 있습니다. 전에는 이제 대형
반도체에 빠졌다가 반등할 때 전기의
주가가 상당히 강했었는데 다른 소부장
대비 크게 움직이는 모습은 나타나지
않고 있습니다. LG 전자 KH바텍
파인 M텍텍 등도 상승세를 보였고요.
이번에 9월 달인가 10월 달에
아이폰 폴더블이 출시가 될 예정인데
또 모멘텀이 앞에 있기 때문에
관련주들이 조금씩 올라가는 모습이
나타나고 있습니다. 뭐 출시 연기에
대한 이야기도 있었는데 애플 측에서는
그대로 나온다라고 또 이야기를
했더라고요. 그래서 주가에 좀 영향이
있었던게 아닌가라는 생각도 들고
플랫폼 섹터에서 네이버 카카오
나머지 뭐 카카오 페이나 카뱅 등도
어 상승세를 보였습니다. 네이버가
너무나 좀 저렴해진 상황으로 보여지긴
하는데요. 포워드로 14배 정도
거래되고 있습니다. 니케이 지수
1.2% 오른새로 마감했는데 뭐
여기도 반도체 IT 종목들이
좋았습니다. 도쿄 일렉트론 2.6,
무라타가 4% 이비된 4, 어드반도
2.3 오르면서 어 소부장 종목들
대체로 양호한 흐름이었고요.
국내 배터리 체인도 상당히
좋았습니다. LG엔솔이 4% 삼성
STI가 8% 급등세를 보여줬고 아래
양극제 업체들도 9% 이상의 상승세를
보였습니다. 지금 단기적으로 좀
2차전지도 많이 빠졌는데요. 원스
기준으로도 그렇고 한 3개월
기준으로도 그렇고
상당히 약한 모습이 나타나고
있습니다. 자동차 섹터 봐 주시면
현대차 2.7 올랐고 나머지 정들도
한 4%대부품이나
SI 쪽에서 올라오는 모습이었고요.
소비 섹터 봐 주시면 아모래 퍼시픽의
주가가 5.8% 오르면서 최근 흐름이
좀 양호합니다. 그 외에 코스맥스나
코스메크 코리아는 약세를 시현했고요.
아래 피부 미용 기계는 클래시스를
제외한 나머지의 종목들이
상승세였는데요. 파마, 휴젤, 원택
등이 상승세 보이면서 소비젤 섹터
그래도 최근 흐름 괜찮은 상황입니다.
그리고 음식료 섹터에선 농심이 1.8
8 올랐고 3형식품도 3% 오르면서
음식료도 나쁘지 않았고요. 아래
백화점인 최근에 주가 낙폭이 좀
컸었는데 그래도 신세계가 3.8%
반등하는 모습이었고요. 조선 철감미
기타 섹터 봐 주시면 조선주에서 현대
중공업 중공업은 약보권 전공도로
마감했지만 하나 오션과 하나 엔진
최근에 납품이 굉장히 컸었는데요.
금을장에 반등세가 나왔습니다.
철강화학 섹터도
반등을 좀 일고 하는 모습이었고 아래
방산주로 내려가서 보면 하나로가
1.5, 렉스원이 8% 현대 로템이
11.4% % 급등하면서 방산주에서는
로템이 좀 금요일장에 가장 강한
반등세를 보여줬었던 거 같고요.
원머스 기준으로는 넥이 -3 현대로
14% 마이너스 하나로 하나로가
10% 가량 빠져 있는 상황입니다.
그리고 원전주 최근에 좀 이야기가
잠잠해진 종목 중에 하난데 두사
에너빌리티
연초의 흐름 좋았었던 걸로
기억하는데요. YTD로 3.7% 7%
정도 오음새로
보이면서 연초 대비 좀 많이 약해진
흐름입니다. 그 바이오섹터로 내려가서
보면 삼성 바이오, 삼성 에피스가 한
5% 정도 오 올랐고요. 나머지
코스닥 종목들도 바이오색도 좋았는데
어 금요일장에 말씀드렸던 패트론
악재가 주가에 반영되면서 하한가로
측행을 했고 그리고 HL도 마찬가지로
악재가 있었는데 HBL 주가도 많이
약하 약했던 상황입니다. 지금
프리장에서 아 NXT장에서도 HL가
추가로 한 18% 정도 빠지고
있습니다. 어 그리고 증권이나 금융주
상당히 좋았고요. 특히 최근에
금융주의 주가 흐름이 좋습니다. 엔터
쪽은 하이브를 중심으로 대체로 상승세
보였고요. 변합기 쪽도 많이 빠졌다가
금요일장에 반등에 성공했습니다.
지금 시간해로 18%
>> 네. HLB가 18% 또 하락 중에
있습니다.
>> HLB는 예전에도 뭐 노이즈 한번
읽지 않았어.
>> 자주 읽는 기업이긴 합니다.
>> 그러게.
그리고 노이즈 나오고 또 확 빠졌다가
또 몇 달 지나면 또 반등이 좀
들어오다가
근데 이번에는 또 미국 쪽 FTA승이
또 실패했기 때문에
실적에 향후 실적에 영 연결될 수
있는 부분이라서
단기적으로 반등하기 좀 쉽지 않을지
않을까 싶습니다. 네.
자, 그러면 오늘 리포트 가져오셨는데
보니까 삼성전자 어 우리 KB 김동원
센터장님
자료 가져오셨고 그다음이 네이버 자료
가져오셨네요.
>> 네, 맞습니다.
>> 삼성전자 먼저 보겠습니다.
반도체 주 관련주들 최근에 주가
흐름이 좀 둔화가 되고 있는데 일단
KB 김동원 연구원님은 반도체 주가에
대해 되게 불리시한 분 중에 하난데
뭐 의견을 꺾지는 않으신 거
같습니다. 27년 역사전가작 타이탄
공급이라고 하는데 어 타겟 프라이스
60만 원의 바이 의견을
유지했습니다. 27년 70년 반도체
역사상 가정 공급 타이탄가 될 것으로
어 전망을 했고요. 27년 범역
메모리 신규 생산력 확대가 사실상
전무한 상황에서 내년부터 빅테크 장기
공급 계약이 본격 시작된다라고
합니다. 메모리 신규 생산 물량은
LTA 체결한 빅테크 중심으로 우선
배정될 전망이라고 하고요. 따라서
일반 고객이 체감하는 27년 메모리
공급 부족은 공급 절벽 수준으로
심화될 것으로 전망을 한다. 메타
AI 투자 현황에 대해 이야기도
했는데요. 메타가 26년 7GW 규모
AI 데이터 센터 구축에이어서
27년에 7GW 추가 계획을
어 공시했습니다. 내년부터 총
14GW 확보가 목표라고 하고요.
26년 메타 AI 투자 금액이 약
220조원 정도로 예상이 되고 있고
올해 미국 BT테크 전체 AI 투자
20%를 메타가 차지할 전망이라고
합니다. 메타 2분기 실적 공골에서
27년 7GW 투자가 공식화됐고요.
시장의 투자 지속성 우려가 단번에
해소 허세되는 어 강력한 시그널이
이번에 확인이 됐다라고 합니다. 저는
사실 이거 메타에서 7개W 규모
발표하고 나서 주가가 좀 강하게
반등할 줄 알았거든요. 전자나
하이닉스 금요일장에서. 네 생각보다는
주가 흐름이 약했었습니다. 어 최근
전자의 주가 조정 배경 및 전망에
대한 이야기도 했는데요. 최근 조정은
메타 데이터 센터 임대계획 관련 AI
투자 지속성 우려와 삼성전자 2분기
실적 고점 논란이 겹친 결과로 보고
있고요. 저크버그 CEO는 블룸버그
인터뷰에서 AI 산업에서 컴퓨팅
자원이 충분하다고 느끼는 사람은 없을
것이다라고 언급을 했습니다. 컴퓨팅
자원 임대학 계획은 임대를 통해 AI
투자비를 단번에 회수한 일론머스크의
XAI에서 영감을 얻었다라고
밝혔고요. 삼성전자 영업 이익은
3분기 110조, 4분기 124조로
예상이 되고 2분기 대비 실적
개선폭이 확대될 것으로 보고
있습니다. SK하이닉스 ADR 강세는
SK하이닉스 본조와 삼성전자 주가
상승으로 이어지는 연세 효과가
기대된다라고 하고요. 이에 따른
반도체 리이팅의 선순환으로 이어질 것
같다. 긍정적인 비율을 유지했습니다.
아래 실적 추위 차트 추정치를 보면
27년 예상 매출액으로 940조 정도
보고 있고요. 영업 이익은 574조
전망했습니다.이 중에 DS 사업가
566조로 대부분을 차지할 것으로
추정이 되고 있고요. 영업 이익률
내려가서 보면 올해가 52.5,
내년 61.1입니다. 1입니다. 영업
이익률이 한 9% 포인트 정도 내년에
추가로 개선될 것으로 보고 있고요.
지금 일각에서는 내년 영업 이익률이
유지될 수 있냐라는 의견들도 나오고
있는데 뭐 대체로 연구님들 중 한
10분 중에 한두 분 빼고는 다
내년에 영업률이 올라갈 것으로 여전히
추정 중에는 있는 거 같고요. 옆에는
포워드 밸루에이션들인데 뭐 PR은
5배 정도 지금 PBR은 2.2배
2배 정도 수준에 위치하고 있는
상황입니다. 그래서 PBR 배수가
과거 사이클과는 당연히 다른 밸류로
줘야 된다라고 생각은 드는데 만약에
이번에 반도체가 이게 고점을 이미
찍고 내려오는 상황이다라고 보면
어디까지 PBR을 봐야 될지 좀
거기에 대한 고민이 좀 들긴
하거든요. 과거에 이제 삼성전자의
피밴드 하나는 뭐 100 깨지면 사야
된다 뭐 이런 이야기 많이 했었고 뭐
닉스는 뭐 0.9배이 900이 정도
깨지면 매수해야 된다라는 이야기가
있긴 했는데 완전 사이클이 조금
달라지긴 했기 때문에 그 바닥 잡는
것도 굉장히 어려울 수도 있겠다라는
생각은 듭니다.
자 우리가 숫자를
기억하고 넘어가야 되는데
작년에 44조 정도 나왔는데 올해
380조
그죠? 네. 거의 아홉배에 증가하고
그러고 나서 내년에
>> 574조
영업 이익이
증가하는 걸로 나와 있습니다. 그리고
영업 이익률이 중요한데요. 영업
이익률이 피카웃 치는 거 아닌가?
그런 부분을 체크를 해야 되는데
>> 올해 52.5%
내년에는 61.1%까지 1%까지
영업 이익률이
증가하는 걸로 돼 있고 뭐 반대
반도체 부분만 이제 또 발라서 봐야다
보니까 올해는 68.3
내년에는 73.2
요렇게 예상을 하고 있습니다.
하이닉스는 그러면 내년에
80% 넘어가겠네.
>> 영업 익률이요?
>> 네. 이미이 숫자대로라
>> 추정치는데 80% 83인가
봤던 거 같고요.
>> 네.
하이닉스가 더
어떻게 보면 반도체가 아직 살아
있다라고 가정하면 더 좋을 수도 있는
거는 HBM 쪽에 대한 노출도가 더
높은데 HB 가격 인상이
어 내년에 곧 나오잖아요. 계약
가격이 그러면 한 두 배 정도 올라갈
것으로 지금 추정이 되고 있어서 물론
영업 이익률이 절대적으로 너무나 높기
때문에 전자는 여기서 89% 포인트
내년에 추가로 올라간다고 하지만 어
하이닉스도
지금 HBM에 대한 가격 인상을
반영만 해 주면 주가가 상당히 강할
수도 있겠다라는 생각은 듭니다.
>> 근데 최근에 그 HBM보다 그냥
디램이 마진이 더 좋다고 그러잖아요.
>> 네. 그래서 AC 가격 인상인데
>> 그래서 아 인상을 하니까네
더 마진이 더 좋아지는
그림이
>> 오늘 나온 리포트 보니까 하이닉스
2분기 계실적이 컨센을 하위할
거다라는 이야기가 있더라고요.
>> 아 그래.
>> 네. 네. 뭐 HBM 쪽에 대한
이야기를 하면서 네
>> 아직 가격 인상도 반영이 안 됐고 뭐
그런 부분을 감안해 보면 이분기 때는
조금 컨센데비할 가능성도 있다. 이런
이야기 하고 있습니다.
>> 어 그래요.
거기 선구 매니저는 어떻게 설명해요?
어, 저도 그럴 가능성이 있다라고
생각을 하고 닉스 같은 경우에는
80% 영업 이익률은 바로 당장이
3번기부터 넘어갈 가능성이 좀 큰 거
같고
>> 기존에도 말씀드렸긴 하지만 3번기 때
영업 이익 추정치가 한번 대폭 상형
조정될 가능성이 높다라는 말씀을
드렸었는데 그게 이제 3분기 때
진행될
Hm 가격 협상이 끝나게 되면은 바로
어 증가사들 쪽에서 목표이 추장
장치를 한번 대폭 사용시켜서 좀 큰
거 같습니다. 어요.
어 그러면
주가 흐름이 조금 어 전방이
[콧방귀] 오히려 큰을 좀 하여할 수
있다면 실적 발표 때까지 오히려 좀
주가가 약했다가 오히려 발표하고 나서
반등이 들어가는 그런 그림으로 좀
수정을 해야 되겠네요.
그러면 마이크론도
거의
컨센 하여할 가능성이 마이크론이
이번에 이제 발표했고 그죠?
>> 예.
>> 3, 4, 5월 발표했었죠.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 6 7 8
>> 예
>> 실가 9월이 나올 건데
>> 아무튼 그
지난 금요일 날 하이닉스는 15%
올라가는 아 13% 정도 미국에서
올라간다 그죠? 마이크로는 1.2%
정도 더 빠른
>> 근데 그 수출 금액 단가 아까 이제
10일마다 나오잖아요. 근데 HBM
단가가 최근에 굉장히 급하게 올라가고
>> 아 다시 올라가고 있구나. 네. 그게
왜 그래서 좀 추정이 되는 거를 좀
내용들을 살펴보면은 엔비디아 쪽으로
나가는 거 같은 경우에는 연간 단위로
이미 획스를 해 놨기 때문에 가격을
못 올리는데
>> A직 쪽으로 나가는 HBM 같은
경우에는 이미 단가를 올리기 시작을
했다라는 얘기들이 좀 있긴 합니다.
어 그럴 수가 있고 지금 7월 달은
3분기 실적이 이제 잡히는 거니까
그 2분기 실적을 약간 하여할 수
있는 부분을
실적 발표가 되면 오히려 어 8 9
10 8 9 10이 강할 수가 있겠
거예요
>> 밑에 무슨 표도 있잖아요네
>> 아 이거는 저번 주에 보여 드린 건데
그 말씀해 주셨던 모은 스탠니가
리포트를 발표했을 때 그 적중도에
대해서 네. 좀 알아봐 달라고 하셔서
첫 페이지 그 다음 페이지로 넘어가서
보면 될 거 같은데요.
2016년도부터의 자료가 쭉 있는데
제가 데이터를 놓고 GPT한테 좀
만들어 달라고 하니까 이렇게 해
주더라고요. 그래서
>> 내용을 살펴보면 핵심 보고서 핵심
내용 이렇게 나오고
>> 2016년도부터 쭉 있고요. 매물리
슈퍼사이클을 저 당시에 전망을 했었고
>> 어 삼성전자 하이닉스 둘 다 이제
실제로 슈퍼사이클을 맞이해서 주가가
상당히 강했었는데 저때도 맞췄었고요.
그래서 큰 흐름으로 보면 24년
9월부터 이제 조금씩 적중도가
떨어지기 시작했거든요. 언제부터
>> 2024년 9월
>> 한마디로부터
>> AI 반도체가
이제 시작된 이후부터 좀 적중도가
떨어지기 시작하는 걸 저희가 알 수가
있는데
>> 14년 9월 달에 윈터스 윈터
룸스라고 했는데
>> 음
>> 이때 실제로 주가 추위를 보니까 두
달인가 빠집니다. 두 세 달 정도
그래서 닉스가 20만 원 위에가
있다가
>> 13만 원인가까지 빠졌었고요. 근데
시장에서 예상했던거나 모건 스탠리에서
예상했던 것보다이 AI 수요가 훨씬
강했고 H에 대한 수요가 강했기
때문에 그 이후로 주가가 한 두 세
달 만에 좀 올라갔던 기억이
있습니다. 그래서 어쨌든 뭐
결과적으로 이거 맞다 틀리다라고 볼
순 없지만 좀 어쨌든 1년 정도 뷰로
보면 이때 의견은 틀렸었다 하면서
바로 24년 10월 달에 정정
보고서를 냈었죠. 그래서 단기 전망은
틀렸다라고 인정을 하고 목표가를
재상향한 바가 있었습니다. 그다음은
빙산이 다가온다라고 하면서 25년
4월 달에 이야기가 있었는데요. 이때
관세 리스크를 좀 꼽았었고 보이지
않는 위험이다라고 경고를 했었는데이
당시에 주가는 뭐 반도체 실적이나
이런 거에 큰 영향을 주지 않았지만
어쨌든 관세 여파에 대한 투사자들의
두려움이 발생하면서 주가가 좀
흔들렸던 기억은 있는데 어쨌든 업항
자체는 실제로 흔들리지 않았기 때문에
어 적중 여구에선 틀린 걸로 어
보여지고요. 그다음 메모리 슈퍼
사이클이라고 해서 25년 9월 달에
어 제시했고요. 투자 회견은이 당시에
상향 HBM 공급 부족이나 AI 서버
수요 확대를 전망을 했었습니다.
그래서 타겟 프라이스를 어떻게
올렸는지도 볼 수 있는데요. 어
전자를 한 8만6,000원에서
9만6,000원으로 사용 조정을
했었고 닉스 이심 중에서 41만
원으로 사용 조정한 바에 있었습니다.
그래서 적 이단이 당시는 좀 적중하는
모습이었고요. 그다음 최근에죠.
20년 7월 상승장에 마무리라고 해서
픽아웃 신호가 나왔다라고 했는데
여기서 이제 하이퍼스케일러들을 좀 더
선호한다라고 의견을 제시를 했었고요.
빅카웃은 올해 하반기에 영업률이
고점을 찍고 내년부터 이제 내려오지
않을까라는 전망을 하면서 반도체
비중축소을 최근에 어 낸 상황입니다.
그래서 총 정리해 보면은 AI
이전에는 굉장히 적중도가 높았고 그
이후에는 좀 적중도가 좀 반반 정도로
내려간 거 같다라는 생각입니다.
음.
자,이 보고서가 워낙 중요하다 보니까
어, 좀 정리를 해 봐야 되는데
2016년 17년에 메모리 수서
아이클라고 이제 보고서 제목인 거죠.
그러면서 삼성전자 하이닉스에 대해서
어 롱을 했었던 거고 근데 17년
11월 달에 보면
폴드 메모리
time to sleep 근데 이제는
좀 어 그동안 고마웠는데 많이 먹어지
고마웠는데 이제는 좀 잘 시간이
됐다.음 음. 그렇게 나오고
어 2017년 11월 달에 전자는
그때 액면 분할 때문에 미리 고점을
찼어요.
2018년
4월 달에 하이닉스가 4월인가 5월
달에 고점을 치는데
한 번도 랠리가 있고 그러고 나서
이제 빠졌는데 그때 다시 한번 픽
메모리라고 고청고를 한 번 더 했었고
그러고 나서 주가가 이제 박살이 나
버려요. 박살이 박살이 나고 있는데
그게 주가만 빠지고 이익이 안
빠졌으면 또 24년처럼에
틀렸잖아 이럴 수가 있는데
2018년도에
어 삼성전자가 58조 8,000원이
하이닉스가 20조 7,000원 이렇게
얘기 났다가
>> 삼성전자는 그다음에 27조 하이닉스는
그다음에 22 2조 7천
>> 해 가지고
>> 완전히 이익이 박살났죠.
그래서 결국은 되게 적종을 했던
거예. 근데 2019년도에
반도체가 1년 내내 - 30% 성 그
역성자 얘기할 때 그 실제 데이터가
그렇게 나올 때 리커버리라는
어 리포터를 냈었군요.
제고가 감소해서 이제 회복한다.
그래서 2019년도에
어 이익이 박살이 났는데 주가는
삼성전자가 40% 이상 오르고
하이닉스가 60% 이상
예. 얘네들
홀이 맞았던 거죠. 우리가이 반도체
이익이 어떻게 됐느냐가 아니라 주가
관점에서 우리 뭐 주식 투자하는
사람이니까 주거 관점에서 봐야 되는데
하여튼 기가 막히게 얘네들의 콜이 어
적종을 했었던 거죠. 그다음에는
2020년 뭐 서버스요.
그러다가 21년 8월 달에 윈터
is카 com미. 그러면서 21년에
5월 달에 하이닉스 고점 찍었었는데
어 마이크론도 마찬가지였어요.
삼성전자는 1월 달에 96,800원
고점이 나왔었고 하이닉스가 21년
5월 달에 1500원 고점이 나왔는데
그러고 나서
6 7 8 9 10월까지 해 가지고
주가 많이 빠져요. 많이 빠지는데
근데 요때도 조금 그랬었던게 위
겨울이 온다라고는 돼 있었는데 실제는
그렇게 저거 하지 않았어요.
그러면서 주가가 21년 말에
삼성전자는 이제 8만 원 하이닉스는
14만 3,000원 정도까지
올라오죠. 반등이 마이크로는 오히려
신고가가 나 버렸던게
2022년 1월이었기 때문에
윈터 is com이라는 말을 쓰기에는
좀 애매했었고
아무튼 그러고 나서 한 두 달 영량을
줬다가 예 실제로 실적이 꺾이지 않기
않았기 때문에 아파르게 이제 반등이
들어와졌습니다.
22년도에까지
이익이 좋았었는데
어 메모리 다운 사이클이라고 하면서
어 또 계속 쇼코를 했고 근데
22년도에는
패드가 이제 금리를 올리고 또 러우
전쟁 터지고 그래서 뭐 반도체가
안 좋았다기보다 그냥 전체적으로
시장이 안 좋으면서 다박산
그런 거였고 그다음에 23년도에 AI
메모리이 긍정적인 있잖아 하고
그러다가 24년 9월 달에 생통밖에
또 윈터
얘기 어 저기 겨울이 이제 또
다가온다.
참 그러면서 그때 당시에 보고서
우리가 거의 뭐 쌀fully이 다
뜯어봤잖아요.
>> 뜯어보고 아니 AI 모멘텀이 시작이
됐는데 왜 레거이 반도체만 얘기하고
있냐는 거지.
그래서 얘네들 반성문 쓰게 될거다
했는데 10월 달에 정정 보고서 뭐
단기 전망은 틀렸지만 뭐 하면서
반성의 의미는 안 별로 안 보였어요.
그래서 어 우리 방송을 보고 있나?
예. 좀 자존심 어 반성이 반성하는
태도가 중요하죠. 어 그 뭐
물어봤으면 예 틀렸어요. 뭐
단기적으로 틀렸어요. 약간 이런
느낌. 예 반성하는 태도가 안
보였었는데.
그리고 25년 4월 달에
여기서 보 보면 약간이
더디 아이스 룸스 해 가지고 이게
타이타닉은 연상시키잖아.
타이타닉에서 저 멀리 빙산이 쑥 타고
오는 어우씨 그러면 타이타닉 같은
그런 걸 연상시키는 걸 하필 관세
폭탄 그 바닥에서이 리포터를
그게 진짜 반성문을 써야 되는데
그러고 나서 반성문을 안 썼다가
25년 9월에
메모리 슈퍼사이클이라고
어 약한 뒷부
주거가 얼마나 많이 올랐는데이
뒷북이었는데
아니 그런데 어 하이닉스 많이
올라가고 삼성전자는 못 올라갔겠죠.
근데 마이크론하고 뭐 삼성 하이닉스
같은 경우가
25년 작년 9월에요 리포터 나오면서
9월 10월 11월 해 가지고
올해까지 상당히 좋게 됐었어요. 근데
약간이 리포트를 보면서는
어
모건 스탠니의
그 클라이언트들에 대한 서비스
형태의 리포트인가? 어 숏 잡고 있는
하우스를 위해서 숏 리포터를 좀 세게
예 세게 내주면서 주가를 다 내가
리포트 내서 주가 어 빠졌지 어 봤지
어 뭐 약간 요런 느낌이
모든 거는 다 제일 개인적인
생각입니다. 예 어 섹터에 건강한게
아니라 그런 리포트를 그동안에 보면서
어 느낀 생각이었고요. 그런데 어
중요한 거는 영향력은 있다는 거죠.
맞지 않는 부분이요 AI 사이클
들어와서는
맞지 않는 부분들이 좀 반반 있긴
했었는데 아 얘네들이 참 영량력은
여전히 좀 세다.
>> 그래서 이번 영량력이 어느 정도까지
영향을 줄지음
>> 좀
>> 해야 될 것 같고요. 계속이 부분은
어이 메모리 아까 김동은 센터장님의
의견부터 해 가지고 계속 이제 서로
상충되는 의견들이 나오니까
>> 보면서 누가 누구 얘기가 많든지
>> 예 계속 저도 저희들도 타당성을
>> 검정해 보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 자 그다음에 네이버 리프트 한번
보겠습니다.
네이버 관련된 이야기인데요. 단기
수익성 하락할 것으로 보고 있고
중장기 성장 동력은 유효하다라고 해서
삼성 오동안 연구원 자료했는데 매출
성장은 견조 수익성은 하락인데
2분기에도 네이버는 견점 커머스
매출이 있었을 거고 전분기와 유사한
16%의 YY 매출 성장률을 보일
것으로 전망했습니다. 광고 매출은
커머스 광고조로 yyy 9% 증가하고
커머스가 포함된 서비스 매출도 월
월드컵 기간 플러스 멤버십 가입자
증가및 삼성 감사제 냅다 세일 등
프로모션 확대로 yy 33% 정도
성장했을 것으로 추정을 했고요.
시장이 위축되고 있는 웹툰 콘텐츠를
제외한 파이낸셜이나 뭐 엔터프라이즈
C2C 커머스 전반이 성장하면서 전체
매출 성장을 견인했을 것으로
추정했습니다. 견조한 매출 성장에도
GPU 감각 삼각비나 월드컵 중계,
커머스 마케팅 비 전반적인 비용
증가로 2분기 이익은 Y와Y 1.4%
증간 5,300억 정도 나오면서
컨센을 한 8% 하회할 것으로 추정을
했고요. 어 지속적인 비용 상승
압력을 받고 있다라고 하는데 올해는
GPU나 CPU 구매 확대에 따른
감가 상각비 멤버십 대상 무제한 무료
배송 반품 관련 비용이 있을 수 있고
매장 결제 단말기 MK페이 커넥트
보급 관련 원가 증가로 비용 증가가
불가피하다라고 합니다. 비용 증가로
단기 수익성 하락은 불가피한
상황이라고 하고요. 광고 커머스 매출
증가가 늘어난 비용을 얼마나 빠르게
상세하느냐에 따라서 수익성 회복
시기가 결정될 것으로 전망했습니다.
AI 광고와 투자 증가가 나타나고
있다라고 하는데요. 하반기 매출
정장의 핵심은 AI 검색과 수익화인데
A 7월 AI 브리핑의 광고도입으로
전체 광고 매출 성장률을 두 자리대로
반응시킬 계획인데 AI 검색 확대는
클릭수를 감소시킬 수는 있겠지만 AI
검색 결과가 높은 전환율을 보이고
있고 높은 광고 단가 적용이
가능한만큼 전체 매출에는 긍정적 효과
우리가 기대할 수 있다. 구글이 AI
오버뷰와 AI 모드에서 광고를 본격
적용한 25년 5월 이후 광고 매출
성장률이 상승한 것처럼 네이버의 광고
매출 성장률 역시 하반기 AI 광고
수익 과학 이후 높아질 것으로 전망을
했습니다.
그래서 왼쪽은 분기별 매출액 추위
표인데요.
뭐 매출이나 이익이나 그래도 꾸준히
10% 이상대 성장세를 현재 기록하고
있는 상황이고요. 이익 증가 매년
이렇게 하는 거 보면 사실 미국
빅테크와 큰 차이는 없을 정도로
이익은 꾸준하게 잘 늘어나고 있는
상황인데 뭐 여전히 시장에서는이
AI에 대한 또 출도에 대한 밸류
디레이팅을 계속 하고 있는 상황인 거
같고요. 그래서 오른쪽으로 넘어가면
영업 비용단이 중간 상단쯤에 좀
나오는데 비용이 분기별로 계속해서
늘어나는 모습이 관찰이 되고
있고요.이 이 부분이 내년 내 5후년
되면 이제 본격화되면서 더 비용이
많이 집행될 예정인데 네이버가 데이터
센터 임대 사업을 하겠다라고 밝혔고
어 내년에 아마 200MW 정도
28년까지 증서를 한다라고 이미 밝힌
바 있거든요. 그래서 이전에도
말씀드렸다시피 2030년까지
한 1000W까지 그니까 1GW 그
증서를 할 것으로 지금 회사에서
밝히고 있는데 1GW면 시장 가치에서
한 20조원 정도로 와주는데 네이버가
최근에 저번 달인가 주가 한번
급등해서 PR 20배까지 갔었잖아요.
그때 그 200MW 증서라는 거를
주가에 한번 반영을 했다가 결국엔
그걸 누구한테 임대할 거냐라는 또
의구심이 드는 거거든요. 확정이 돼야
이제 실제로 주가나 실적에 반영을 할
수가 있을 텐데 그 부분이 현재는
아직 어 불확실하기 때문에 주가가
다시 좀 많이 내려온 상황이고요.
메타가 15배까지 빠졌다가 이번에
데이터 센터 임대 사업 한다라고
하니까 그
>> 어 클라우드 사업하고 임대도 한다고
하니까 피아 20배까지
올라갔더라고요. 최근에. 그래서
[콧방귀] 네이버가 지금 13배
정도의 거래가 되고 있는데 이미 이제
디레이팅은 많이 돼서 할인을 많이
받고 있는데 실제로 그 데이터 센터
임대 사업을 본격화해서 숫자로 찍힐
수만 있으면
최소한 18배 20배까지는 다시
올라갈 여력은 충분히 있는 회사다
생각은 듭니다. 그래서 물론 비용을
쓰기 때문에 이전처럼 꾸준하게 이익을
안정적으로 찍을 수 있을지 모르겠지만
시장에선 지금 플랫폼 회사들한테
안정적인 이익보다는 어떻게든 투자해서
향후 이익이 늘어날 수 있는 룸을
확보해라 그걸 원하고 있잖아요. 그
부분을 네이버가 그래도 알고 있기
때문에 주가가 뭐 13배 수준에서는
바텀피 PC 전략으로 사용할 법 하지
않나라는 생각도 듭니다.
요즘 요쪽 요런 부류들이 다 반등이
들어가고 있는데 뭐 메타뿐만 아니라
알리바바도 최근에 반등 들어가지
않았으세요?
>> 어 맞세요? 아리바바도 반등 들어가고
시험이 튼센트 다 반등 들어가고
있습니다.
>> 그죠?
>> 네.
>> 그래서 약간이 메모리 반도체랑 어
요쪽 플랫폼 기업들하고는 어 주가가
당 시소 게임처럼
>> 예. 그렇게 이제 좀 반복되는 그런
모습들이 예
>> 좀 나오고 있고
>> 방금 된 생각인데 주식은 이제 성장주
좋아하시는 분들이고 성장주 이번에도
어 샌디스크 뭐 뭐 엄청 올랐잖아요.
아홉대 정도.
>> 예. 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 올라가고
우리나라 시장도 최근에 작년에 70%
오르에도 70% 대상.
>> 네. 그런 시장이 있고 그다음에
네이버나 농심이나
>> 뭐 이런 주식들 보면
>> 뭐 이익게 단단하게 나오니까
>> 그냥 박스 딱 쳐 놓고
>> 아까 열렙배 뭐 밑으로 내려가면 사고
>> 또 올라가면 무슨 성장 스토리 때문에
올라가면
>> 또 팔고 그냥 눈 감고 그죠
>> 줄 꺼 넣고 매매하는 주식들이 있어요
보면.
>> [콧방귀]
>> 그래서 한편으로는 어 우리도 이름
상품을 좀 다양한다면은
>> 음
>> 그렇게 줄 꺼 놓고 밑에 가면 사고
올라가면 팔고 안정적으로
>> 그런
거도 괜찮겠다. 그런데 그런 매매하는
사람들도 꽤 많아.
>> 예. 뭐 그죠.
>> 예. 펀드 중에 안정 성장형 펀드 뭐
이런 것들도 있었잖아요. 예.
그래서네. 가치주의주로 하면서 그
밸류에이션이 과도하게 하락하면
정성화될 거를 기대하면서
사고 정상화되면 팔고 뭐 이런
>> 예 이런 뉴의 어떤 스타일도 괜찮을
것 같습니다.
>> 괜찮을 것 같지만 [웃음]
별로 안 하고 싶어요.
안 하고 싶은데이 성장주가 좀 눈에
안 보일 때는 어 그런 주식들이 또
올라가게 돼 있어요.
>> 올라가지 있습니다. 왜냐면 저 같은
사람이 이제이 그런 생각들이 막 들기
때문에 그러면 돈이 또 그쪽으로
옮겨가는 현상이 있습니다. 그런
시장도 있다라는 거
기억하시면 좋을 것 같습니다. 자
오늘 월 준비한 자료는 어 다 한 거
같고요. 오늘 밤 아 지금 시장
어떻게 되고 있습니까? 네,
시작했고요. -0.85%로
하락해서 출발을 했고 어, 현재는
-0.25%입니다.
어, 살짝 반등 들어가고 있네요.
>> 네.
>> 네. 야간 [콧방귀] 선물은 살짝
플러스고
>> 예, ETF는 살짝 마이너스였었는데
>> 최초가 좀 낮게 시작했다. 그죠?
마이너스 염
>> 네.
>> 그
무슨 이슈가 뭐 호르모저 해야 뭐
그런 뭐 이슈 있습니까?
>> 예. 네. 뭐 그 미국하고 일란하고
또 스카터가 하는 이슈가 있어서
나스닥 선물 아침에 좀 안 좋았고
유가가 한 3.1% 정도 상승을 했을
거 같아요.
>> 자, 그리고 코스닥은 어떻게 됩니까?
>> 네, 코스닥 플러스 0.27%로
상승해서 출발했었고요. 현재는
2.63%까지 상승폭 확대하고
있습니다.
>> 네.
코스닥은 반대로 강세가 이어지는 그런
모습이 나오고 있습니다. 자, 지난주
금요일 미국 시장 전부 다 월플러스
예상을 했었거든요. 결과는 어떻게
됐었죠?
>> 결과도 올플러스가 있습니다.
>> 폭이지만
>> 예, 올플러스 났고. 자, 오늘 밤
미국 시장 어떻게 됩니까? 주%.
어 오늘 밤
>> 애매하다 그지?
>> 네.
>> 아 애매하네.
>> 오르길 바라는 마음으로 상상하겠어.
>> 오르길 바라는 마음으로.
>> 네.
>> 어
주식 몰빵 지금 현금이 없을 것
같은데 느낌이
>> 없습니다.
>> 현금 없죠?
>> 네.
>> 국내 주식에요? 미국 주식에요? 둘
다
>> 아 둘 다
자 알겠어 자 나스닥은 어떻게
예상해요? 상승하 있습니다.
>> 상승
>> 네
>> 어떤 이유로
>> 어 전반적으로 기술주가 변조원
들어주고 있는
국이랑 이런 갈등 측면에서 새로운
이슈가 추가적으로 더지 않는다면 좀
해서 마감하지 않을까
>> 오케이 기술제의 상승세가 좀 더
이어질 것 같다. 예 그런 얘기를 해
주셨습니다.
필반 지수는 어떻게 될 것 같습니까?
이번 주 화수 목이 좀 분기점이 될
거 같은데 화요일은 물가가 나오는
거죠. 수요일은
ISM 아 목요일은
TSMC 이렇게 나오거든요.
>> 주요 이벤트를 앞두고
지난주에
아 대체로 어 반도체 대형주 그리고
반도체 섹터 지수가 조금 올랐거든요.
그래서
약간음 소강 상태가 되지 않을까라고
생각을 해서 지금 소폭 조정으로 생
얘기하겠습니다. 어 약간 약보합
정도.
>> 예 약보합 약간 하락. 예.
>> 약간 하락.
>> 예.
>> 자 그리고
국내 시장 보겠습니다.
코스닥은 어떻게 돼요?
>> 어 코스닥 여전히.
>> 여전히 연봉.
>> 네.
>> 아 코스닥 좀 바닥친 느낌이 지난
주에 있어 가지고
>> 네.
>> 이번 주 좀 강세가 좀 이어지지
않을까?
>> 네. 상하는데 호스닥 여전히
시스템에서는 음봉.
>> 네.
>> 지난주 목금은 일단 양봉 양봉
나왔습니다.
하지만 시스템은 음봉이라고 했고.
자, 코스피 한번 볼게요.
코스피 오늘 양봉날 가능성
높을 것 같고요. 근데 오늘 되게
믹스랑 닉스는 빠지고 전자 조금
오르고 나머지 그 소부장이나
다른 섹터가 다 오늘 강해한
상황이네. 2차전지 자동차 뭐 변합기
전부 다 오르는데
>> 반도체는요 정도만 움직여 줘도 그냥
부합 정도인데
양복날 가능성이 높다라고 생각합니다.
>> 양복네
코스피 양봉
자 주요 종목들 동력 보니까 전자는
플러스고 하이닉스 마이너스는
3.44네 사자.
>> 네.
>> 그러니까이 하이닉스 ADR 상장하면
급등할 거니까 하이닉스 주가도 같이
올라가지 않을까? 약간 요런 이벤트
드리으로 생각하면서
[콧방귀] 어 살짝 반등이 좀 있었긴
했었는데 지난주 주 후반에
>> 예.
>> 별 재미는 없네요.
>> 네.
>> -3.5% 5% 빠지면서
210만 원 지금 기록하고 있습니다.
298만 7,000원 대비해서는 지금
30% 정도 거의 빠졌니다.
>> 자, 전자 하이닉스가 쉬면 어 시장
끝났다. 뭐이 시장 끝난다. 뭐 이런
얘기 하신 분들 많으셨는데
제가 그렇지 않다고
어제도
그 세택에서이
부동산의 파숑 기막년
대표가 운영하고 있는 다독이라는
>> 어 책 읽어 주는 코도 있어요. 음
>> 거기 20만 돌파 기념으로 그
설명을 했었는데 거기서 가서도
말씀드리는게
부동산
그 빠숑 김학영 대표가 부동산 쪽에서
합의
그래서 부동산하고 비교해서 제가 많이
말씀드렸는데
강남에 지금 악구정이나 반포나 평당
1억이 평당 2억 됐단 말이죠.
그러면 마용성, 여의도 목동, 평당
모천 언저리 하다가 어 저기가
2억이야 하면이 같이 올라가면서 상당
지금 6, 7천 8천 이래 쭉 오르고
있거든요.
>> 음.
그리고 노원 상계 도봉도 어 평당
2,000원 원절리 하다가 뭐야
저기가 2억이야 하면서 올라가고
있어요. 요즘은
대구 수성 해운데도 덜썩들썩 부동산은
이제 그렇게 올라가는데 주식은 참
신기하게도 삼성전자 하이닉스가 그
평당 2억 만들어 놓은 것다라고
보시면 2천조 2천조했잖아요.
>> 예. 그러면이
목동 마용성 여의도 같은 데가 5,
7, 8,이 돼야 되는데 최근 그런
불류의 주식들이 5,에서 3천이 돼
있어요.
>> 음.
>> 거의 대부분의 주식이 -40%가
있잖아. 보면
>> 그래서 야, 참 앞으로 먹을게 너무
많다.
>> 음.
제가 봤을 때는 평당 7천으로 가야
될 주식들이 지금 평당 3천으로
오히려 빠져 있으니까.
>> 음.
>> 그게 이제 밸류에이션 관점으로
쳐다보면 뭐 그런 것들이 보이는데
어 그냥 주가 흐름만이나 이런 걸로
보는 분들은 아이 반도체 끝나면 다
끝나는 거야. 이렇게 얘기하시거든요.
>> 음.
>> 그렇지 않다는 거죠.
그래서이 반도체가 쉬니까 막
튀어오르잖아. 왜 막 튀어오르냐면
>> 평당 7천 가야 되는데 지금 평당
3천은 오히려 빠져 있으니
>> 그래서 제가 주식이 너무 좋다는
거죠.
>> 근데 이걸 이해하지 못하면 돌아버리는
거죠. 말 그대로 돌아버리는 거예요.
도대체 내 주식만 왜 이래? 그래서
그걸 이해하지 못하고 막 신용 쓰고
있는 사람들 안대 매매 당하고 말
그대로 돌아버리는
자 그런 걸 어 이해를 하시고 예
투자를 하시면
우리가 조금 조금씩 주식적에 대해서
좀 그 속성을 이해를 하시면 주식으로
돈 벌 수 있는데게 너무 많고 행복한
투자 여정이 될 수 있을 거다. 그런
말씀이 드립니다. 그러니까 이제
정모님이 하신 말씀 이제 핵심이 이제
가격과 같이 타일을 알아야 되는데
가격만 쳐다보고 있으면은 다
만나온다는 얘기죠.
>> 그러니까요. 가격 좀 빠졌다고 막
불안해 하시고
>> 그런 분들은이 가치와 가격 제일
중요한게 이제 가치 평가거든요.
>> 그 가치 평가가 안 되면서 내가
오르고 내리고 맞추기 게임 하고 있는
거잖아요.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 네. 그런 의미로이 주말에 별주 부천
할 때도 보면 뭐 미국 주식, 한국
주식 예 보면 끝에 캔슬링 분석을
하잖아요.이 캔슬링 분석을 하면서이
펀더멘탈리의 변화가 있는지 그게 가치
평가를 해 보는 거예요. 근데 그
가치 평가를 하지 않고 수많은
방송에서 아 지난주에 무슨 주식이
많이 올랐고 뭐 이런 거는 교통
방송이에요. 교통방송 교통방송 백날
그걸 뭐 10년 쳐본다고 실력이
오르겠습니까?
그래서이 조금 어려우시더라도이
가치 평가에 대한 그 개념을 항상
생각하시면서
주을 하시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
네. 저희가 별주부전도 그러고 오늘
아침 모닝 브리프에도 그렇고이
화면 조정이라든지 여러 가지 많이
지금 애를 쓰면서 어 약간 좀 더
퀄리티가 좋은 방송이 어 되고 있는데
조만간에이
스튜디오를 확비할
생각이 우리 라운지 대회신을
>> 아예 스튜디오로 만들어서
>> 음
>> 네
>> 훨씬 좋은 방송이
한번 해볼 순간입니다. 기대하시고요.
자, 오늘 최슬님 모니브리퍼 7월
13일 전선는 여기까지 하겠습니다.
이번 한 주도 건강하시고
아이팅 넘치시는 그런 한주 되시길
바라겠습니다. 고맙습니다.
감사합니다.